GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY THIS
AND HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTAL
COME TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AT
CHURCH SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO ONE OR TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS PROVIDED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
1-877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN FIVE NINE TWO
SEVEN FOUR THREE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIAL LONDON ZERO. OF FOUR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ASSIGN YOUR LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOT READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU. ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTAMENT TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. HELLO MY
TEAM THE QUORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT A
HEARING IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME. MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LATIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS FOR JUSTIN TO THE
NEW USE. OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS TO.
KNOWLEDGE SHE CONSIDERATIONS
AND CLEANING PROTOCOLS WE WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. ACCORDINGLY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WILL
BE LIMITED TO THREE MINUTES
EACH. ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. WE HAVE FIFTEEN BILLS.
ON TODAY'S AGENDA- HOWEVER WE
ARE NOT HERE A. B. SIX SIX FIVE
TO DATE THIS BILL HAS BEEN.
SAID TO BE HEARD IN THE
COMMITTEE ON JULY SIXTH. WE
HAVE FOUR BILLS ON CONSENT
THOSE ARE AB THREE NINETY SIX
BUT GABRIEL A. B. SIX FORTY
COOLEY AB NINE SEVEN SEVEN
GABRIEL AND AB EIGHT SEVENTY
THREE. RAMOS. AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- CONSULTANT
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
HER TADO PRESENT. JONES
COURTESY. KAMLAGER YOUR- DAN.
WE HAVE A CORE WE ARE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM. AND AT
THIS MOMENT WE WILL- MOVE ALONG
WITH. THE FIRST. PRIDHAM WE
HAVE ANOTHER HERE READY TO
PRESENT AND THAT'S ITEM NUMBER.
A ONE AB TWO TWO- ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR HAND AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- GIVEN YOURWORKLOAD I SUSPECT YOU WANT ME
TO BE BRIEF. SO THEN I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK IN THE
SAME SPACE AND TAKING UP THE
TIME TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE BILL
CERTAINLY I'M A- STRONG
SUPPORTER THAT UP IN AND ALSO
THIS MY FIRST LIKE TO START BY
TAKING THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND THANK YOU FOR HELP US TO
MAKE IT BETTER BUILT. EYES YOU
KNOW AB TWO TWO OF TWENTY ONE
WOULD PROVIDE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS OF FOOD EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE FOR LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA'S REGARDLESS. OF
DOCUMENTATION STATUS OR NOT.
AGAIN GIVEN THE FOOD INSECURITY
PARTICULARLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC IN THE LONG LINES THAT
WE SEEN AND NEED. I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE.
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. AND WE
HAVE TWO WITNESSES- GOOD I ALSO
ASKED TO BE BRIEFED GIVEN
COMMITTEES WORKLOAD- NATALIE
CAL- COMPILERS FROM THE
CENTRAL- CENTER CALIFORNIA FOOD
BANKS. AND FOR QUESTIONS IN THE
INTEREST OF COMMITTEES TIME- WE
ALSO HAVE YOUR OF PRESENTERS
AND THE WESTERN CENTER FOR LONG
POVERTY- IN HAD A TEAM. THANK
YOU AND- WE CAN BEGIN WITH A
WITNESS NUMBER ONE. WE HAVE TO
HAVE NATALIE ON THE CALL. WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU CAN YOU SPEAK
UP PLEASE. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME.
HELLO. WE CANNOT HEAR YOU CAN
YOU SPEAK UP PLEASE. MAY NOT
TURN OUT TO MANAGER. I MEAN.
GIVE US. MISTER BRICKNER HOW
CAN YOU HEAR ME ARE WE CAN HEAR
A LITTLE BIT MORE. OKAY I'M NOT
SURE WHAT THE PROBLEM IS. IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GETTING THERE.
OKAY. OKAY IS THAT BETTER YES
PLEASE AGAIN. OKAY I AM SO
SORRY I THINK IT HER HER TADO
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUY I'M
NATALIE CABLE CODE PO CENTER
PROBABLY BE BANK SERVING FRESNO
MADERA HE TULARE AND KERN
COUNTY. ALL OCCUR ISSUE AND
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA PRIOR TO
THAT BUT ONE AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCING FOOD
INSECURITY BUT LACKING THE
LINES THAT ARE DISTRIBUTION
EXPLODE OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN
MONTHS I'VE BEEN TRULY
HEARTBREAKING. AND IT'S BECAUSE
OF THE UNDENIABLE FACT THAT THE
LONG NOT THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC. DEPICTED IN THIRTY IN
OUR STATE THAT I WAS
DISAPPOINTED NOT TO SEE EIGHTY
TWO TWENTY ONE INCLUDED. IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUDGET PROPOSAL. A
TWO TWENTY ONE WOULD PROVIDE A
REAL LIFELINE IN THE FORM AND
THE FOOD BENEFIT CARD TO
EMIGRATE CALIFORNIANS BURKE
PLEADED BY CONTRAST. AND PER
CENTRAL CALIFORNIA THAT
INCLUDES MANY IN OUR FARM
WORKING COMMUNITY FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO CUT FOOD ON OUR
TABLE. THE FOOD BENEFIT CARD
WOULD BE ABLE TO BE DISTRIBUTED
AS AN IMMEDIATE EMERGENCY
BENEFIT. WITHOUT A LONG
APPLICATION PROCESS WHICH WOULD
HELP BOTH THE BANKS. IN THE CBO
DISTRIBUTING THE FOOD CART AND
HELP KEEP ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
WELL. I KNOW THAT OTHER
SWEEPING PRIORITIES INCLUDING
FOOD CO THAT THE BOXES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT WORRY
COULD IN THE LEGISLATURE'S
PROPOSED AT FUNDING IN THE
FINAL BUDGET. BUT I WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT WE WILL STILL
NOT BE ABLE TO MEET THE
INCREASED DEMAND FOR IT BUT THE
RECORD LEVELS OF HUNGER THAT
WITH EACH DAY. ADDITIONALLY
MANY IN OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES
ARE STILL FACING BARRIERS
ACCESSING OUR TRADITIONAL
DISTRIBUTION AND NOT A QUIET
THE BENEFIT CARD OUTLINED IN
EIGHTY TWO TWENTY ONE OF
HERSCHEL. IT REALLY DOES ON
EXISTING GAP REACHING SOME OF
OUR MOST VULNERABLE NEIGHBORS
DURING CRISIS. I APPLIED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO
LEADERSHIP AND THE BIPARTISAN
ASSEMBLY ONE VOTE EIGHTY TWO
TWENTY ONE AND ACTIVISTS. BEING
ACTED THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NATALIE DO
WE HAVE CHRISTOPHER ON THE CALL.
MANCHESTER HERE TO SUPPORT ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IN THE
INTEREST OF AUDIT COMMITTEES
TIME OKAY GREAT THANKS A SO
THEN ARE WE WILL MOVE ALONG TO
A PUBLIC COMMENT AND SUPPORT
BEGINNING IN ROOM THIS ROOM
FORTY TWO ZERO THREE. SEVEN
NINE OUR ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SEEN ON THERE AS WELL- WE WILL
MOVE TO- A PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE TELEPHONES. YEAH GOOD
MORNING GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN
HAS BEEN CLOSE TO CALIFORNIA
WILL PROVIDE CIRCULAR EDITION.
IS STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT CALL AND LAYS
DOWN ON THE BOTTOM LINE IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME IN ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. ENSURE THIS TIME WE DO
HAVE ABOUT THIRTEEN IN OUR
QUEUE. OKAY I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE US. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME POSITION AND AT THE
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU'RE WITH
AND WE'LL GET STARTED WITH-
OPENING UP. INDIVIDUALLY OF THE
LINES. ABSOLUTELY AND WE'LL
START WITH LINE EIGHTY ONE. AT.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON JASON FROM
AROUND THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE IN THE PROGRAMS OF
STATION AND BURNS FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT IS SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON
PAUL YOU'RE A BE UP FOR THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY ALL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT TO BE NUMBER SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
YOU AN FOLLOW NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXUS LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT ZERO AT. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WILLIAM
AREA
RESEARCH EDUCATION OPEN AND- IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR- THOUSAND MORE
MEMBERS HE JOHN ON BEHALF OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHT CHIRLA UNDER
WHAT THE MEDICAL AND THE GRANT
IN. YOU TO CORAL. A. B. TWO TWO
ONE. THANK YOU. TEXAS LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN THE- A GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MARTHA GUERRERO REPRESENTING
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT IS FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME THREE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EXCLUSION IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWO TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BINEY EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS THE
BEST LOKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
AND FARMING NETWORK WE ARE INTO
FOUR ALONG WITH NINETEEN OF OUR
MEMBERS- WELL QUICKLY NAME- BUT
A FRIEND ON ALAMEDA
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK CALIFORNIA
KLEIN AND ACTION NETWORK.
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM CARBON CYCLE INSTITUTE
NINETY PROJECT ECOLOGY CENTER
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP BY
THE SHED. OF THE YEAR LATINO
COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA LUTHERAN OFFICE OF
PUBLIC POLICY CALIFORNIA
BRENTWOOD POLICY COUNCIL
NATIONAL YOUNG FARMERS
COALITION CLASSIFIED ACTION
NETWORK NORTH AMERICA SECOND
HARVEST REPUBLICAN. VALLEY HERE
HARVICK. ANNABLE ARTICLE AND
YOU. ACT PROJECT AND THE FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS WHAT.
THANK YOU IN YOU. TEXAS SIXTY
SIX GO AHEAD. THE BILL CAN
REPAIR CALLING ON BEHALF OF MY
COMMUNITY I THINK IT'S BEEN
REPAIRED AND YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SURE YOU TO MARK ON
BEHALF OF THE PRIVATE PRACTICE
PROJECT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
BLIND EIGHTY FOUR IS GOOD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHAT'S WE FAVOR ON
BEHALF OF GLIDE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVENTY SIX THESE GOOD. MADAM
CHAIRMAN SENATOR ADEMOLA GIVES
BIRTH BEGINNING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
THE SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO TO ONE.
THANK YOU. WHINY EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NEW
MANICURED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
CALL. EACH REPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BY NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MICHAEL
RIGHT AGAIN I'LL BE OUT WITH
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FINE NINETY
PLEASE GOOD. THANK YOU
CHANTILLY PATHETIC CALIFORNIA
LOCATION OF THE BANK CONCERT
FOR EIGHTY TWO TWENTY ONE THE
COURT R. NATALIE CABLE
STATEMENT AND STRESSED THAT
CALL CALIFORNIA THE BANKS ARE
UNDER SIMILAR STRAIN I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
EIGHT GOOD. NEARLY ALL OF THE
ACTING ON BEHALF ON WELFARE
DIRECTOR. IMPORT THANK YOU. BY
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS BENJAMIN SHALL CALLING
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ENDOWMENT
POLICY CENTER HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO ONE.
THANK YOU. BLIND NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON CARE
MEMBERS OF THE FOR THE WATER
CALLING THE CALIFORNIA TRAVEL
THE COFFERS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB. ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BY NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SANTOS ON BEHALF OF S. E. I. U.
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NONE LEFT IN OUR QUEUE IS
CONTINUE MANAGER. THANK YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL MOVE ON TO ANY
OPPOSITION AND AT THIS POINT WE
HAVE NO. LEAD OPPOSITION ON
THIS BILL- BUT WILL MOVE INTO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL BEGIN AND IMPROVE
FORTY TWO. ZERO THREE SEEN NONE
OF ROOM. TWENTY FORTY. NO
OPPOSITION THERE- WE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENTS LINE FOR THOSE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO AB
TWO TWO ONE. AND IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWO TO ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. IN ONE SPROUT FISSION.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU- BUT I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THINKING THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD ON
FOOD IS- A BASIC NAY BUT WE- WE
KNOW THE PEOPLE ALL ACROSS OUR
STATE ARE SUFFERING FROM HUNGER
AND FOOD INSECURITY. AND
IMMIGRATION STATUS SHOULD NOT
KEEP PEOPLE FROM ECEIVING FOOD
ASSISTANCE- WE NEED TO TAKE A
SWIFT ACTION TO ALLEVIATE
HUNGER- WITH URGENCY. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
EFFORT TO FEED THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONGST US UP. AT
THE SMALL AT THIS MOMENT I'LL
MOVE IT OVER TO ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THE BILL. I THANK YOU
CONNECT OKAY THREE NINE- WE
HAVE A MOTION. AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR EITHER THANK OKAY AT
TEN KING PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TWO TO ONE BY SANTIAGO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
HER TADO I. FOR TITLE II JONES.
COURTESY CORTESE I COM LONGER I
COM LONGER AYE PAN NIGHT AN
ONLINE. OKAY WE WILL PLACE THIS
BILL ON CALL THANK YOU AND- UP
NEXT WE HAVE. SB SIX SEVEN
AGENDA ITEM TOO BUT BEFORE WE
PROCEED I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
QUICK MOMENT TO APPROVE THE
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SO- CONSULTED KEEP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON THOSE. WITH HIS
ENCOUNTER DO NEED MOST THANK
YOU WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
PAN. AT AT CONTROL TO KEEP
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO ADOPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THOSE ARE AB THREE
NINE SIX BY GABRIEL AB NINE
SEVEN SEVEN BY GABRIEL EIGHTY
SIX FORTY BY COOLEY. AB EIGHT
SEVEN THREE BY RAMOS. HER
TITLE. I TITLE II JONES CORTESE
RIGHT CORTESE I COM LONGER I
COM LONGER I'D PAN BY AN ONLINE.
HEY WE WILL PLACE AT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ON CALL THANK
YOU. OKAY AGENDA ITEM TO- AB
SIX SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CALDERON PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB SIX SEVEN
ZERO SIX TO PROVIDE PROTECTIONS
FOR PARENTING FOSTER MINORS AND
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS PARENTING
FOSTER YOU STRUGGLE TO ACCESS
BASIC SUPPORTS NEEDED FOR THEM
AND THEIR CHILDREN TO THRIVE.
CONSEQUENTLY THESE YOUNG
PARENTS ARE HIGH RISK OF LOSING
TEMPORARY OR EVEN PERMANENT
CUSTODY OVER THEIR CHILDREN.
DESPITE THE STRIDES MADE BY THE
STATE LEGISLATURE IN PREVIOUS
SESSIONS THERE ARE STILL GAPS
IN CURRENT LAW THAT WORK
AGAINST PRESERVING THESE FAMILY
UNITS. AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SB SIX
SEVENTY SIMPLY CONTINUES
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS TO ENSURE
PARENTING FOSTER YOUTH ARE
SUPPORTED IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
PARENT THEIR CHILDREN. I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. REMOTELY BY
PHONE TIFFANIE CORTEZ FROM THE
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA AND ISABELLA ORVILLE
A FORMER CLIENT OF THE
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER PUBLIC
COUNCIL. WE HAVE LEAD WITNESS
NUMBER ONE ON THE CALL. PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY YES I'M
HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON SHANNON
HAD HAD- AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE MINOR AND NON MINOR TO.
THAT REPRESENT. CALIFORNIA MY
NAME IS THAT THE COURT HAS A
NINE THE SEAT AT THE TOURNEY
SUPERVISOR HE'LL BE IN MONTEREY
PARK. TWENTY SIXTEEN I'VE HAD
THE PRIVILEGE AND THE
REPRESENTING THE THANK YOU AND
AMONG THE AMAZING POPULATION
AND REPRESENT A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF MINOR AND NON MINOR
TO. WHO ARE SOME OF THE MOST
RESILIENT AND AMAZING PARENTS
AT RENOWN I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU ONE OF THEIR STORIES
AND WHY EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY IS.
SO IMPORTANT. IN FEBRUARY
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AT AGE
SEVENTEEN. MY CLIENT TWO
CHILDREN WERE DETAINED AND PLAY
FOR THE PATERNAL GREAT
GRANDMOTHER. AFTER A VERY
HIGHLY CONTESTED HEARING. SHE
WENT INTO A VERY DIFFICULT
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS DEGREE
INDICATION SERVICES. DUE IN
LARGE PART TO HER STABILITY
WHICH ARE SOME OF THE REASONS
WHY HER CASE CAME IN AFTER THE
PENDANT. SHE WAS UNABLE TO
REUNIFY AND THE CHILDREN WENT
INTO PERMANENTLY PLANNING A
FAMILY. ALTHOUGH DURING THIS
TIME SHE MAINTAINED A VERY
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH BOTH OF
HER CHILDREN. THREE YEARS LATER
AT AGE TWENTY WHILE SHE WAS
STILL A NON MINOR CONTENDED.
SHE HAD A NEW BABY THAT WILL BE
PAINTED BURKE. DURING THE TIME
SHE WAS BRIEFLY INCARCERATED
AND MADE APPROPRIATE PLANS BUT
DUE TO THE DEPARTMENT AFFECTING
HER HIGH WITH THE HARD. BECAUSE
OF THE PREVIOUS HISTORY AND
WALTER CURRENT INCARCERATION.
THE RECOMMENDATION WAS AND NOT
PROVIDE HER WITH FAMILY
REUNIFICATION THIRD OF THE
THIRD CHILD. THEY DID NOT AND
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ANY OF THE
CHANGES THAT SHE HAD MADE.
AFTER THREE YEARS AND A LOT OF
GROWTH INCLUDING PARTICIPATING
IN THIRD BALLING HARD RATED
AFTER HER RELEASE. SHE WAS NOT
ONLY ABLE TO REUNIFY WITH THE
THIRD CHILD AFTER A HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE DIVISION HEARING
SEVERAL MONTHS LATER. HE
ACTUALLY CLOSED EXCESSIVELY.
WITH NO CONCERN SIX MONTHS
LATER. TODAY MY CLIENT HAD ALL.
SUCCESSFULLY FOR A MOTION AND
RE. WITH THE FOLDER TO CHILL
THAT WOULD. AND TWENTY SEVEN.
THE DEPARTMENT INITIALLY
RECOMMENDED ADOPTION OF THE TWO
CHILDREN. NOT BELIEVING THAT
SHE EVER WOULD HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO PARIS AND SAFELY.
BUT NOW ALL THREE CHILDREN IN
HER CARE AND BRIBING. SHE
STABLE. WORKING IN SCHOOL AND
PROVIDING A LOVING HOME FOR ALL
THREE OF HER CHILDREN. WHO ARE
NOW ABLE TO PROVIDE WE'RE NOW
AT A LIVE IN A HOME TOGETHER
ACTIVELY. IT'S A SOCIAL WORKER
IN THE DEPARTMENT INITIAL
RECOMMENDATION OF NO FAMILY
REUNIFICATION GRANTED. ALL
THREE OF THESE CHILDREN WERE
NOT OF THE TURN HOME AND NONE
OF THEM WOULD HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY KILL THE TRAUMA. OF
THE PAST FIVE YEARS THE VERY
YOUNG FAMILY AND NOW ALL THREE
OF THEM ARE TOGETHER WITH THEIR
MOTHERS THE PLATE. AND WE DO
ANTICIPATE THAT IN OCTOBER HER
CAPABLE TO BE OLDER TWO
CHILDREN BOB. DOLE IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THAT OUR YOUNG
CHARACTER BASIC AND- IF YOU'RE-
THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF HER
CHILDREN THE CHANGES ARE. BUT
SHOULD NOT BE HELD AGAINST HER
THREE YEARS LATER ESPECIALLY
WHEN THEY'RE RELATED TO THE
VERY REASON FOR KATE COMING FOR
THE KIDS. TO GET WET.
ADDITIONALLY HER PRIOR BECAUSE
THE HISTORY OF THE MINOR SHOULD
NOT. BE CONSIDERED A RED. THE
REASON THAT SHE CAME TO THE
SYSTEM ONE IS USED AGAINST HER
AT THE PARENT AND THE COMPLETE
JACK ARE MINOR. AND MODERATE.
THE GROWTH THAT PLACE BETWEEN A
TEENAGE YEARS AND YOUNG ADULT
YEARS BUT SIGNIFICANT AND IS
BILL TO GIVE ALL OF OUR YOUNG
PARENTS A CHANCE TO SHOW THE
WORLD. AND HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO RAISE THEIR CHILDREN WALLET
KNOWLEDGE IN CHANGING
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY TO HELP STOP THE
GENERATIONAL CYCLE THE FOSTER
CARE. I NOTICED QUITE VERY VERY
WELL AND I CAN SAY THAT IT IS
AN AMAZING THING TO WATCH HER
BE ABLE TO PARENT HER CHILDREN
AFTER SO MANY PEOPLE DOUBTED
HER. AND I THINK THAT IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT YOU REALLY HEAR
WINE YOU FOR EACH UNDERSTAND
WHY A BILL LIKE THIS. AGAIN
IT'S NOT JUST SOMETHING IN
WRITING OR SOMETHING THAT YOU
SHOW THE BUNCH THAT THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE. SIGNIFICANTLY
AFFECT THE LIVES OF OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR CHILDREN'S
CHILDREN AND THERE ARE SO MANY
OF THE YOUTH THAT I HAVE
REPRESENTED THAT IT HAD A VERY
SIMILAR STORY. I THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING AND I HOPE YOU WILL
CONSIDER THAT WENT. AFTER THE
BELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR LEAD
WOULDN'T NUMBER TWO. PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. MANY
WITH THE DEVELOPER. YEAH ON THE
PHONE CALL SHARE SORRY NINE
MARCH ON INTO TEMPORARY
ANYTHING REMOTELY FUN WHEN I
WAS TWENTY YEARS OLD AND AN
EXTREMIST ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
ALTHOUGH COUNCIL AREN'T WE- WHY.
OKAY THE BIRTH OF MY CHILD I
WAS ABLE TO CONNECTING THE
PUBLIC COUNCIL CHILDREN LAW.
PUBLIC CANCEL HOLDING PROTECT
ME PANICKING RIGHT AND HELP ME
AND JACOB- MEAN JACOB MY
PARTNER MEETING CAN'T BE A. A
CHILD. I WAS JUST TALKING.
ASSEMBLY INTENT TWENTY NINETEEN
I REPORTED TO MY THERAPIST MAKE
PARTNER JACOB AND I GOT AN
ARGUMENT. OKAY MEDIA REPORTS
ABOUT WHAT THE- HFS BEGAN
INVESTIGATING THAT ALLEGATION
AND I NOTIFIED PUBLIC COUNCIL
INVESTIGATION. RECITATION AT
SOME POINT WITH BOYFRIEND.
DURING THE EARLY PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION- IN JANUARY OF
TWENTY TWENTY PUBLIC COUNTY
STARTED PROVIDING ME WITH LEGAL
APPLICATION DURING THANK YOU
CAMPUS INVESTIGATION. PUBLIC
CANCEL ATTORNEY MELINDA-
INTENDED MEETING WITH ME AND
CHECK THAT AND IF YOU SEE IF I
CAN GET THE GEAR AND SHE
ADVOCATED FOR ILLEGAL TURN
MAIN. IN OUR CARE. MONNING ANY
LEGAL ADVICE REGARDING THE
INVESTIGATION. ALTHOUGH THE
DETAILS AND YOU SEE COURT CASE
FOR CHILD WE WERE ABLE TO KEEP
A CO OWNER KAREN IN OCTOBER
TWENTY TWENTY THE OPIATE THAT
THAT'S REALLY ADVOCATED.
MYTHICAL FOURTEENTH. I THINK
DIFFERENT PART TIME PARENTING
HAVE THE COURT I'VE BEEN
INTERNING THEY DO SO. TO GET
HERE FAST- THE DESTINATION
REGARDING THE CHILDREN. YOU
CAN'T PURSUE. BOTH OVER A LOT
OF MY RIGHT YOU CAN NEVER
BECAUSE I'M YOUNG AND I HAVE
MUCH INFORMATION ABOUT IRATE
AND PROBLEM A PERSONAL UNIQUE A
LOT OF PERSONAL INFORMATION
THAT WOULD NOT REALLY GET THEM.
THANK YOU WELL BE INVESTIGATED.
ON HAVING AN ATTORNEY MELINDA
COACHING THROUGH THEM BACK FOR
THE EDUCATION ABOUT MY NOW WE
ARE GOING. SO MANY MARK
COMMUNITIES. THEY DON'T GET THE
REST AND DIGNITY THAT IS
SOMEONE FOR SEVEN. AGAIN THANK
YOU CAN YOU NEED. THEY CAN
TRUMP. ON YOUR RIGHTS IN THE-
AND IF YOU HAVE THE OF AN
INTERN. AND THANKFULLY NOT
COUNT HELP ME MAKE. MY CHILDREN
HOME BECAUSE. ALTHOUGH BROWN OF
THINGS THAT WEREN'T RELEVANT TO
MY QUESTION STONE. EIGHT
THANKFULLY I HAVE THAT YOU CAN-
OTHER FROM. MEETING MY FAMILY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YOUR
TESTIMONY- AT THIS MOMENT WILL
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
SUPPORT A HEARING. FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE THREE NINE MOVING
ONTO ROUTE TWENTY FORTY. SEE
NON- WILL MOVE TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE ON ALL
THOSE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX SEVEN ZERO.
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. THEN SHARED THIS
TIME WITH ABOUT SEVEN IN THE
QUEUE. OKAY ED DISTURB REMINDER
TO ALL THOSE- WAITING TO STATE
THE POSITION PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME- YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
AND THE ORGANIZATION THAT
YOU'RE WITH AND- LET'S BEGIN
WITH THE FIRST FIRST CALLER.
WE'LL START WITH LINE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BUT PACKAGING SALAS
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. LINE SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS DANIELLE ONE
DRUG WITH CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BY NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HELLO THIS IS ERIC WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. BY
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE CENTERS ON BEHALF OF ACT
III YOU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. BLIND ONE HUNDRED
THIS GUY HAD. AFTERNOON PICK ME
PAN ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATES ASSOCIATION OR
CALIFORNIA CASA IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVENTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
PINE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
SABRINA FOR TAKING THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ALL OF THE EFFORTS ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMONWEALTH-
DOCTORS WITH THE- THANK YOU. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU THERE'S NO LEAD OPPOSITION
FOR THIS BILL BUT WE WILL MOVE-
TO ARE THOSE THAT ARE WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
BEGINNING IN ROOM FORTY TWO
ZERO THREE. C. NINE OKAY MOVING
ON TO A TWENTY FORTY. SEEN
UNDER AS WELL I WILL MOVE ON TO
THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT
CLIENT AND THOSE- WITH A
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. IN THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS
ZERO. TEN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE THANK YOU AT
THIS MOMENT I'LL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS SUFFER ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. AND WE
HAVE FOUR QUESTION OR COMMENT
FROM SENATOR PAN JUST JUST
BRIEFLY- REALLY APPRECIATE-
THIS EFFORT TO BE SURE THAT WE
HELP PROVIDE SUPPORT TO-
PARENTING FOSTER. YOUTH WHO ARE
NOW PARENTS THEMSELVES AND WITH
THAT I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU ASCENDER PAN AND- WE
WILL GO HEAD AND- PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITY CLOSE. AB YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
SENATOR PAN- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE. OKAY WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN AND
ALCOHOL TO KEEP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB SIX SEVENTY. BYE
CALDERON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST. AT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
HER TADO I FURTADO I'D JONES
CORTESE BY PROTESTS THE I. COM
WALKER HI COM LONGER AYE PAN HI
AND I. WILL PLACE THE BILL ON
CALL. AND WE HAVE UP NEXT
AGENDA ITEM THREE A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE. METERS TO
SUCH. ROOM. SERVE COMMUTERS. WE
WILL BE TAKING A QUICK FIVE
MINUTE RECESS- AND WE WILL BE
BACK SHORTLY THANK YOU.
WE WILL BEGIN WITH- AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER THREE. A. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY TO SOME WOMAN CALDERON
PLEASE- PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT SIX TWO STYLISH THE
ENHANCED SERVICES PROGRAM FOR A
SLIGHTLY EASE OR ES PA FOR
SHORT WITHIN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
INDIVIDUALS GRANTED ASYLUM HAVE
LEGAL PROTECTION STATUSES DUE
TO THE THREAT OF PERSECUTION
BASED ON THEIR RACE OR
RELIGION. AS SILENCE DIFFER
FROM EDGE REFUGEES AS A START
SEEKING PROTECTION UPON ARRIVAL
TO UNITED STATES WHILE REFUGEES
SEEK HELP WHETHER STILL IN
THEIR HOME COUNTRY. UPON
ARRIVING TO THE U. S. REFUGEES
ARE ASSIGNED A CASE WORKER TO
HELP CONNECT THEM WITH THE
SOCIAL SERVICES THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR. THIS INITIAL
CONNECTION WITH THE CASE WORKER
IS NOT MADE FOR SITE LEASE
RESULTING IN MOST SOCIETIES
HAVING TO NAVIGATE THE
COMPLICATED SOCIAL SERVICES
SYSTEM ALONE. WITH THE CREATION
OF THE S. P. A. AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WILL MIRROR WHAT IS
OFFERED TO REFUGEES FOR SITE
LEASE THE S. P. A. WILL PROVIDE
ISRAELIS WITH CULTURALLY
COMPETENT CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES FOR UP TO NINETY DAYS
AND WITH IT ACCESS TO ALL THE
BENEFITS IN WHICH THEY ARE
LAWFULLY ENTITLED TO. I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY OF POLAND A
POLYNOMIAL SORRY APOLLO MORALIS
FROM THE COALITION OF HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND RENEE. TOM
BANG IN THE SAILLY FROM
CAMEROON. OKAY OUR HOPE OF A
LONGER LEAD WITNESS NUMBER ONE
TO BEGIN. MODERATOR DO WE HAVE
A BILL ON A VOTE ON THIS ON THE
PHONE. I DO NOT SHOW THAT
THEY'VE DIALED IN. THANK YOU I
WILL MOVE ON TO LEAD WITNESS
NUMBER TWO- RENEE TROMPING. DO
WE HAVE THAT THAT INDIVIDUAL ON
THE CALL. BURNAGE CHOMPING YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DO SHOW THEIR CONNECTED I'M NOT
SURE IF THEY HAVE ITSELF MUTED.
HELLO HELLO OKAY IS THIS FOR
NAY. YES SPEAKING HI RENEE WILL
IF DON'T MIND SPEAKING UP A
LITTLE. OKAY OKAY WE CAN HEAR
YOU BETTER NOW PLEASE AGAIN.
I'M READING SOMETHING ON A
DAILY FROM FAMILY OWNED AND I'M
HERE SUPPORT THE AB TEST. SIX
EIGHT. BECAUSE I HAVE GONE
THROUGH THIS. ALSO HAVING A
SEVEN. OF TO ME AND I KNOW
IMPACT BOTH FOR ECONOMICALLY.
MORALLY I THANK. WE ARE COME
HERE EVEN THOUGH WE COME THE
FRIENDLY. THE MAIN DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN I'M NOT I WHO JEEZ TO
MEET DEMAND OF ENTRANCE INTO U.
S. WITH THE SAME. I'M THE
MOVING FROM A COMPLETE
DIFFERENT COLOR IN I'M NOT COLD.
H. ALREADY SOME WHICH IS VERY
VERY TO MY. MILD CASE MY FROM
THEY CAN BE DOING THE HEIGHT OF
COURT AGREED IN DECEMBER I HAD
LOST MY JOB IT GAINED IN
OCTOBER. I'M I'M NOT HAD A JOB
IT HAS BEEN REALLY REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR US. SO I'M GOING
TO SUPPORT BILL BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT ESPECIALLY I'M- IMMIGRANTS
SOME I THINK THAT THEY DO NOT
EVEN NOTICE THAT IT'S IS THAT
I'VE BEEN ABLE. BUT THE NGOS
ARE GIVEN THE MANDATE TO HELP
THEM. THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
DIRECT THEM WITHIN THE FIRST
NINETY DAYS THE FIVE MINUTES IT
IS ALWAYS A VERY COLUSA. IN
SOMEBODY'S LIFE BECAUSE THAT'S
THE PIERATA OF RESETLEMENT. I
KNOW YOU DON'T WANT TO START
RESETTING THE ROLE WE- VOTED
GUARDIANS OF EAST COAST SOUTH
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE JUST COME
IN. TO BE ABLE TO LOG AND LEFT
FROM THERE RIGHT. I'M TO
BENEFIT ALSO FROM THE SERVICES
THAT ARE BEING OFFERED TO
REVIEW G. IT IS NOT EVERYBODY
WAS ON BOARD SHOWN TO BE ISSUED
IN THE COUNTRY BECAUSE- THEY
ARE FROM CURRENT COUNTRY DATA.
APPROACHING TO HAVE THE TPS
STATUS IN THE UNITED STATES AND
THERE ARE THOSE WHO DO NOT HAVE
THE STATE THAT THEY CAN SO THEY
ARE FORCED TO FLEE. TO THE
UNITED STATES. I THINK WE ALL
FALL UNDER THE SAME CATEGORY OF
REVIEW G. I'M SHOULD BE
ASSISTED IN THE SAME WAY THAT
YOU COULD DECIDE THIS STATE.
BUT WE CAN ALSO RESET THE HERE.
I'M STOP STOP LIFE. ON A GOOD
FOOTING BECAUSE OF THE TRAUMA
YOU GO THROUGH BEFORE YOU EVEN
GET INTO THE UNITED STATES. ITS
AUDITED SO MUCH DISSECTING DOWN
YEAH THE NEW BUT THE NO MONEY
NO ADVICE NOTHING YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW THE COURTS. I MEANS
OF OPENING UP A BANK ACCOUNT OR
IT'S NOT EASY FOR ME- THIS I
THINK THAT IF I HAVE. CASE
MANAGEMENT. I WILL NOT WE GET
FREE. SO I'M REALLY CALLING ON
THE SENATE WHO. GAVE THE VOTE.
AND HELP OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAVE
COME AFTER ME AND ALSO. ACTIVE
.COM THANK YOU. LEVINE ONTO THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMON LINE
FOR THOSE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT- BUT LET'S- ARTIST
REMINDER I'D NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE.
SEVEN OF THEIR COLDEST
CALIFORNIA WHAT FROM REGULAR
VISION. AND STRONG THIS. THIS
BILL BE UP FOR GRABS EACH. AND
WHAT STEPS HAVE FAMILY. WHERE'S
YOUR YOU DON'T SO THIS IS WHAT
NEEDED THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WITH. I'M SECRETARY FOR
POLYTECHNIC WATCHES MONPA AND
SOME SUPPORT OF THE MOTHER
THANK YOU. HAMLEYS GERMAN OF
LINE YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF A
THIRD SO EIGHT PLEASE ONE ZERO.
AND ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. ENSURE
THIS TIME WITH US IN OUR QUEUE.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES OF THE-
ALL STAR WITH LINE SIX NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GET
AFTERNOON REBEKAH NATIONALIST
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER BY. BLIND ONE OH
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SAUGUS THE
INTERNATIONAL RESCUE COMMITTEE-
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS FIRST
IN THE NATION TRANSFORMATIONAL
LEGISLATION THANKS. THANK YOU.
WINDS SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOLLOWING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JANET CANNELLA ON
BEHALF OF THE QUALITY OF COURSE
MAINLY RIGHT CAROLINE IN
SUPPORT OF A- ONE SIX EIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. WINE OH
FOUR PLEASE GO. THE IRISH THAT
CARACALLA THE LARGEST
DIPLOMATIC YOU'RE GONNA IN THE
NATION STRONG OR. THANK BY
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ENTER FRAZIER WITH THE LEGAL
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
LINE ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JODY DELLA PENA EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF BURMA REFUGEE
FAMILIES AND NEWCOMERS IN
OAKLAND AND CHAIR OF THE
STEERING COMMITTEE OF THE EAST
BAY REFUGEE AND IMMIGRANT FORM.
ARE TO RETRAIN CASE MANAGERS
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE
INDIVIDUALS AND- REACH LAST
YEAR PER THE SERVICES IN. I IN
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS THANK YOU.%
THANK YOU. PINE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
OAKLAND WHEN ISLANDS- I'M NOT I
WASN'T ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
TESTIMONY BUT I JUST WANT TO
REGISTER- ARE SUPPORT US
RECORDS DEPARTMENT RIGHT FOR
THE BILL THAT THERE'S NOT TO
PROVIDE SOME. MISTER APOLONIO
ED EAT IF WANT TO ADD SOME OF
COM KNOW THE- GOING TO PROVIDE
THE UPPER AND OF THOSE WAITING
TO ATTEST IN SUPPORT PICKED
FEEL FREE TO. I AT ANYTHING
ELSE EMAIL TO. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH I WANNA THE IN OF THE BOB
SB THIRTY SIX EIGHT AND THANK
YOU FOR TAKING LEADERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY LOOKS LIKE- WANNA MAKE
SURE CONSUMERS THAT THERE A
PROBLEM FOR THE BILL WE HAVE
OVER A ORG. THAT'S FINE ON IN
OF A THE PROGRAM WITH HELP OR
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS AWKWARD
ASYLUM HEARING. THROUGH THE
CREATION THE S. A. WITHIN THE
OF OFFICIALS. AND SO WE WANT TO
MAKE FOLKS ARE YOU KNOW US
PUTTING HERE CORE BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE P. HELLO- AND THEY NEED
HOW IN TERMS NAVIGATOR THE COMP
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE HERE- SO
THAT IS TO SAVE THERE TO SEE
EIGHT ALL RECEIVE A FIVE ARE
VOTE OF THE COMMITTEE HUMANS.
AND I ENCOURAGE YOU TO AB THERE
SIXTY EIGHT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MILES PROTEST.
AT CONTINUE. TO MOVE
INDIVIDUALLY AT BUT CALLERS ARE
FOR THOSE WAITING TO TESTIFY
SUPPORT OF. THIRD SIX EIGHT-
NEXT TO LINED NINETY NINE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND CAN HE WAS
WE ARE ALL CAMPAIGN AND WE ARE
STRONG OF AB SIX EIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE ONE- OH
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I NEED
IS GOING ONE THANK YOUNG OKAY
MANAGER WITH BOND MARKET HE
COMMENTED IN COMMERCE. OPEN UP
A PUBLIC COMMENT IN THOSE
PROPOSED BY BEGIN HEARING FORTY
TWO OR THREE THREE NINE UP.
ROOM FORTY. NONE THERE'S WELL-
AND WILK OPEN UP THE LINES WITH
THE AT TELEPHONE A PUBLIC
COMMENT UP FOR THOSE WINTER
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT AND MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THOSE INDIVIDUALLY. AND THOSE
THAT ARE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN
ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU- DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OF THE BILL.
OKAY ASSEMBLY WOMAN CALDERON
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. S. S.
THANK YOU MA'AM- MADAM CHAIR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
OKAY A WE HAVE A MOTION BY A
SENATOR PAN AND IF THE TWO ARE
CONSULTED CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL IN THIS BILL. AB THREE
NINE SPOKE TO GIVE ME AB ONE
THREE SIX EIGHT BY CALLED
AROUND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
FURTADO. I FOR TITLE I JONES.
CORTESE CORTEZ THE I. COM. HI
COM I. P. HIGH AM I. OKAY WE'LL
PLACE THIS BELOW CALL. THANK
YOU. AN UPDATE WE HAVE OUR WORK
AND WE HAVE ITEM SIX AND THAT'S
AB FOR SIX ONE BY VIA PADILLA.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS AB FOUR SIX
ONE REACH THE CELL EMPLOYED
HOURS WORK HOURS FOR. IF THEY
CHOOSE SILVA HOW'S THE REQUIRE
WORK ACT. TO A CAL WORKERS CAN
RECEIVE CREDIT FOR CELL
EMPLOYMENT IF THE HAVE YOU A
MINIMUM WAGE FOUR HOURS THEY
HAVE SPENT. ON THE WORK
ACTIVITY. AS MANY OF US KNOW IT
TAKES TIME BEFORE SOMEONE WHO
STARTS A SMALL BUSINESS BEGINS
TO SEE A PROFIT FOR. FROM OR IS
ABLE TO YIELD A MINIMUM WAGE
FOR THEMSELVES. AS A STATE
BEGINS TO OPEN AND RECOVER IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT EIGHT WE
FOSTER A CALIFORNIA THAT ALLOWS
ALL CALIFORNIANS CALL ALL
CALIFORNIANS PROSPER AND
UTILIZE THE TALENT THAT THEY
HAVE TO GAME. AND DESIRE INCOME
WITH ME TODAY AND TESTIFIED
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SIXTY ONE.
IS KEVIN AS AS A LEARNING IN
THE EXECUTOR DIRECTOR AT THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA.
WELFARE RIGHTS ORGANIZATION. A
GOOD AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS
KEVIN ARE THERE ARE WHAT'S
CALLED TELEF WHAT THE RIGHT
SORT OF ASSUME THE WIND SO
STRONG SUPPORT THIS. THIS BILL
BENEFIT FROM THE- AND ALLOW. A
TROUBLED BENEFIT. WHO USE SELF
EMPLOYMENT AS ONE WAY OF
ACHIEVING. THAT CAN IN THE. THE
BILL BASED- WITH SOMETHING THAT
WAS SHOULD BE A OF A B. SEVEN
WHICH WAS THE TREE BILL THAT
YEAR AND THIS. STRICTURES THE
PART- THE CHANGE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN IN THAT. WE ARE JULY BOTH
THANK YOU. COULD SAID
SHIFFRIN'S DR CLOSE BY. JEFF
HOW PROBLEM PLAN ARTICULATED
FOR CULTURES THAT. IN RECENT
YEARS THE LEGISLATURE OPEN YOUR
I WAS EMBRACED
ENTREPRENEURSHIP- AND HAVE
BORDER THAT BY ENACTING
LEGISLATION HAS RECOGNIZED
NONTRADITIONAL INDUSTRIES THAT
HAVE BEEN A STAPLE IN
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY SUCH AS
THE LEGALIZATION OF STREET
VENDORS BONTA PRODUCT THE
THOUSANDS OF MICRO KITCHEN AND
MANY OTHER PEOPLE OF
LEGISLATION. AB FOUR SIX ONE
THE BILL DEPARTMENT- BY
PROVIDING MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR
COLLEGES. TO CHOOSE PROBLEM
PARTNER NEVADA FOR CERTAIN
ACTIVITY A WORK ACTIVITY THAT
THE PASSION ABOUT I'M A BIG
BELIEVER IN. THOSE VERY KIND OF
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIANS ARE
CURRENTLY THINKING OF
INNOVATIVE WAYS TO GENERATE
REVENUE FOR THE FAULKNER FAMILY
TREE COVER FROM THE PANDEMIC-
AND WE KNOW THIS IS TRUE BASED
ON SIGNIFICANT WE HAVE SEEN AN
APPLICATION FILED- WITH THE
STATE TO OPEN UP A SMALL
BUSINESS. IT IS FOR THESE
REASONS RESPECT. AFTER I BOOK.
THANK YOU- BOTH ARE FOR YOUR
TEST TODAY AND WILL- TO ROOM
TWO A- FOR PUBLIC. AND SUPPORT.
C. NINE I WILL BE MOVING TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NONE THERE
IS WELL- AND AT THIS MOMENT
WILL OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE FOR THOSE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
ON THIS. BILL ONLY PLEASE. AND
THOSE THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BEN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE IN OUR QUEUE. THEN WE'LL GO
TO LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD B. HELLO THIS IS REBECCA
CAN VOUCH FOR THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO OTHERS IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. OKAY WE WILL-
MOVE ON TO THOSE AT. OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL AND AT THE MOMENT WE
HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION- BUT
WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT AT
BEGINNING A ROOM FORTY TWO
THREE. SEE NON A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NUMBER A WELL- THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT. ONE
NOW IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION AB
FOUR SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE OKAY GREAT DIRECT
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER CAN.
THANK YOU IT'S IN THERE FOR
BRING THIS BILL FOR THE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP WHICH IS WHY
ABOUT SHOULD BE AN OPTION FOR
FAMILIES WHO. ARE ON WELFARE AS
A WAY TO. TO GET THEMSELVES
OUT- AND SO THIS BILL IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THAT SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BILL AND BE HAPPY
WITH THE BILL. THANK YOU CENTER
PAN AND- WOULD YOU. LIKE TO
CLOSE THE FAMILY MEMBERSHIP
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PAN AND
CONTROL TO KEEP PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON THIS MEASURE. AB FOUR
SIX ONE BY VILLA PADUCAH THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO AYE
FURTADO AYE JONES. CORTESE
CORTESE I'D CALM LONGER HI FROM
WATER ONLINE PAN NIGHT AN
ONLINE. THANK YOU WILL HOLD
THIS OUT WILL PLACES BELONG
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
UP NEXT WE HAVE AGENDA ITEM
SEVEN ASSEMBLY WOMAN A REVIEW
ON A BEFORE NINE NINE. AND FEEL
FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU ALREADY.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM TURN
MEMBERS- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR NINETY NINE
LEGISLATION WHICH WILL CREATE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
FAMILIES USING REFERRAL
AGENCIES FOR RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES. I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS WHICH
ADDRESSED ADDRESS SEVERAL
CONCERNS RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS
AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS MEASURE. RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES ARE R. C. A
FEES ARE NON MEDICAL FACILITIES
THAT SPECIALIZE IN HOUSING
PERSONAL I SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
AND ASSISTANCE IN ACTIVITIES OF
DAILY LIVING FOR DEPENDENT
RESIDENTS. DURING COVERT
NINETEEN REFERRAL AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN A CRUCIAL PART OF
PLACEMENT DECISIONS FOR ELDER
AND DEPENDENT ADULT AS
VISITATION IS EITHER NOT AN
OPTION OR INFREQUENT TO LIMIT
THE EXPOSURE OF RESIDENTIAL'S
THE RESIDENTS AND STAFF. THIS
LEGISLATION IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY WHAT ALLOW FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESS OF
INFORMATION FOR CONSUMERS
SEEKING PLACEMENT AT A
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY
THROUGH A REFERRAL AGENCY.
THERE ARE SEVERAL PROVISIONS
PROVISIONS WITHIN THIS MEASURE
STRENGTHENING EXISTING LAW
SURROUNDING REFERRAL AGENCIES
AB FOUR NINETY NINE EXPANSION
INCLUDES PENALTIES WHEN A
REFERRAL AGENCY FAILS TO MAKE
APPROPRIATE DISCLOSURES FAILS
TO SEIZE CONTACT AND FAILS TO
SEIZE REFERRALS THE MEASURE
ALSO INCLUDES PROVISIONS
CLARIFYING THAT MISDEMEANORS
ALREADY EXISTING CURRENT LAW
FROM OFFENSES SUCH AS AN
IMPROPER REFERRAL. REFERRALS
CHEN ON LICENSE FACILITY OR
DISREGARDING THE SAFETY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL. AB FOUR NINETY NINE
SEEKS TO PROTECT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES BY CODIFYING A NUMBER
OF REGULATIONS DURING A
REFERRAL SOURCES AND
INTERACTION WITH THE CLIENT AND
INCREASE REGULATIONS ON
REFERRAL SOURCES. THIS BILL
ALSO OUTLINES THE CRITERIA OF
ABUSE AND OR POOR QUALITY OF
TREATMENT FOUND WITHIN AN RCF
VI'S H. R. C. IF HE BY REFER
SOURCE NEED TO BE REPORT TO THE
APPROPRIATE LICENSING AGENCY.
AB FOUR NINETY NINE HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND ON THE LINE
WITH ME BUT TESTIMONY TODAY AND
SUPPORT OUR MONICA MILLER ON
BEHALF. OF CARING DOT COM AND
CLICK BURKE ON BEHALF OF A
PLACE FOR MOM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO I'M
NOT BEFORE WE PROCEED TO OUR
WITNESSES SAID JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION PURPOSES I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. OF THE US
THE AMENDMENTS USE UP TO TODAY-
WERE. BASED ON- THE REVISED
VERSION ON JUNE TWENTY FIRST AT
THE CAN YES THE COMMITTEES
OKAY. GREAT THANK YOU AND WE'LL
BEGIN WITH OUR LEAD WITNESS
NUMBER ONE TO HAVE MR BURKE ON
THE CALL. HELLO THERE CLIFF
BURKE HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YES WE CAN'T. THANK YOU HEY
CLICK BURGO WITH GOVERNMENTAL
ADVOCATES- HERE TODAY FOR A
PLACE FOR MOM- A PLACE FOR MOM
IS A CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT. AB
FOUR NINE NINE WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH A TRANSPARENT PROCESS
TO ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. ARE PROVIDED WITH
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED
TO MAKE AN INFORMED DECISION AS
THEY FIND THE RIGHT FACILITY
FOR FAMILY MEMBERS. A PLACE FOR
MOM IS THE LARGEST NATIONAL
ONLINE SENIOR LIVING REFERRAL
AGENCY WITH HUNDREDS OF HIGHLY
TRAINED EXPERIENCED AND
COMPASSIONATE SENIOR LIVING
ADVISORS. LOCATED IN CITIES
ACROSS NORTH AMERICA INCLUDING
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA. A PLACE
FOR MOM IS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING FAMILY MEMBERS THE
CRITICAL ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
IN FINDING THE RIGHT ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITY FOR THEIR LOVED
ONE OFTEN AT TIMES OF CRISIS.
BASED ON YOUR UNIQUE NEEDS N.
FAMILY BUDGET. AB FOUR NINE
NINE IS THE RESULT OF SIX YEARS
OF LEGISLATIVE DISCUSSIONS.
CONTEMPLATING HOW TO PROVIDE
CONSUMER BENEFIT ORIENTED
NOTICE TO FAMILIES WITHOUT COST
TO THE STATE AND WITH OUT UNDUE
BURDEN TO THE INDUSTRY. WHILE
POSITIVELY CHANGING THE PLAYING
FIELD WITHIN THE INDUSTRY
APPLYING BEST PRACTICES. AFTER
OVER SIX MONTHS OF NEGOTIATIONS
WITH CONSUMER ADVOCATES FOR OUR
CFE REFORM CAR AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. THE VERSION OF
THE BILL BEFORE YOU STRIKES A
GOOD BALANCE BETWEEN CONSUMER
NOTICE AND PROTECTIONS. FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR DISCLOSURES TO
FAMILIES. LIMIT CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST AND PROVIDE BACKGROUND
CHECKS IN INSURANCE COVERAGE
MINIMUMS. SPECIFICALLY AB FOUR
NINE NINE ONE AND ACTIN NOTICE
REQUIREMENT FOR PROVIDING
FAMILIES THE FOLLOWING
INFORMATION. A DESCRIPTION OF
THE REFERRAL AGENCY SERVICES
REFERRAL AGENCIES CONTACT
INFORMATION INCLUDING EMAIL
ADDRESS MAILING ADDRESS AND
TELEPHONE NUMBER. THE REFERRAL
AGENCIES PRIVACY POLICY OR LINK
TO POP THE POLICY PAGE. THE
STATEMENT OF THE REFERRAL
AGENCY WILL BE PAID A REFERRAL
FEE BY THE ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITY. THE STATEMENT OF THE
FAMILY MAY REQUEST THAT THE
REFERRAL AGENCY CEASE CONTACT
WITH THE FAMILY. AND THE
INFORMATION ON THE AVAILABILITY
OF STATE INSPECTION COMPLAINTS
REGARDING FACILITIES. IN
ADDITION THE BILL PROVIDES FOR
BACKGROUND CHECKS ON REFERRAL
AGENCY EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE
DIRECT CONTACT WITH SENIORS.
REQUIRES LIABILITY INSURANCE
COVERAGE LIMITS ANY BACK
CHANNEL REMUNERATION TO
REFERRAL AGENCY REQUIRES A
REFERRAL AGENCIES MAINTAIN AND
DISPLAY A PRIVACY POLICY UNDER
WEBSITES. AND PREVENTS
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST IN THESE
REFERRAL. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO AS OUR
AUTHOR FOR FOSTERING THIS BILL
THIS YEAR- IT IS BEEN A LONG
TIME COMING IN CALIFORNIA TO
GET THESE KINDS OF CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ENACTED. IN IT TOOK
A LOT OF WORK TO REACH
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE INDUSTRY
AND CONSUMERS I PARTICULARLY
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF TO THE
SENATE NEWMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COALITION ON THIS BILL THIS
YEAR AND LAST YEAR. THIS BILL
WHAT'S BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR OFF RIGHT MISTER
CALDERON AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY
SIX IT PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED THIS
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY I WANT TO
THANK THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE ON
THE COMMITTEE LAST YEAR FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. UNFORTUNATELY I
GOT CAUGHT UP IN THE SUSPENSE
FILE- AT THE END OF SESSION
LAST YEAR IN THE MIDDLE OF
COBIT THIS BILL IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT AS THAT THE AUTHORS
STATED IN TERMS OF PROVIDING
FAMILIES WITH CRITICAL
INFORMATION AND- CRITICAL
INFORMATION IN THE TIME WHEN IT
IS NOT EASY OR EVEN POSSIBLE
FOR A FAMILY TO VISIT A
FACILITY- WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND- DO WE HAVE MONICA MILLER
ON THE CALL. YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MONICA MILLER
ACTUALLY ON REPRESENT- A
CONSUMER ADVOCACY GROUP CALLED
AFTER EIGHT AND YOU'RE ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORED BY THE RETURN
.COM ABOUT ONE OF OUR PARTNERS
IN THIS DISCUSSION. THE PERSON
CONTACT YOU WANT TO THANK YOUR
STAFF THE CLOSELY WITH THAT BUT
LAST YEAR AND THIS YEAR AND
YOUR OFFICE AS WELL ON THE
GLOBETROTTERS OFFICE AND HER
STAFF. THANK YOU FOR THAT UNDER
ON THE WORK WORLD TOWARDS IN IN
LARGELY ON. AND RESULT AS
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE TRYING TO
FIND- I THINK THAT LEAD ONE
PARTICULARLY CAN THAT THE CREEK.
IT VERY CHALLENGING BECAUSE-
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOUR WALK
INTO YOU'RE NOT GOING THE
TREMONT DOT COM OR MY MOM POP
HE AND REALLY A TO OUT WHAT'S
GOING ON BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE
ANY REGULATION OF COURSE AN
OVERLAY. THE PMR. ON RCMP WITH
THIS LIKE. AT THE THAT. AND IT
COULD BERGMAN'S. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THE BY THE WAY APPLE
COUPLE OF. BUT CANNOT COMMENT
THAT FROM BUT IN ADVANCE THAT-
DATE THEN WE CAN LAST YEARS AND
IT'S REAL ALLOW. IN LIKE TO
HAVE A BETTER UNDERSTANDING. OF
THEIR CHIU INSTABILITY UNDER A
WHAT THEY'RE GETTING. ON FOR
THEM WHAT IS THE BOOK. BETTER I
COULD BEGIN THE TOWARD THE-
RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE THE COLD
WHICH- IN THE OF COURSE AT NO
THE REAL THE BALLOT. THAT WE-
BEGIN TO CHANGE THAT SAID THAT
THERE NEEDS TO. DONE UNDER BY
AND THAT'S THEY'LL WHAT THE
COMPROMISED THE BUDGET. THAT
ALL OF THE GREEN THAT THERE WAS
AND- THAT NUMBER AGREED TO. BY
ONE PARTY NOT AGREE TO EIGHT
OUR- AND WE RELIGIOUSLY THAT
THE CAR. THAT GREAT WAY TO
ENSURE OUR FAMILY IS. AND THERE
CAN MEMBERS AT THE MEETING IN
TWO. PHILIPPINES ARE WELCOME
FOR. I THEY ARE MAKING GOODCHOI IF YOU CAN. AND WITH THAT
WE ORGANIZE OUT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. NINETY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
THREE IN OUR QUEUE. WE'LL START
WITH LINE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON HAD SHARED MEMBERS
BAXANDALL REPRESENTING SIX BAD
DOT INK AND ASSOCIATES RESIDENT
CARPET SO FOR THE ELDERLY IN
DEVELOPMENT DISABLED OR
SOMETHING OF A TWEENER AT WE
WANT YOUR IN A LIKE A OF THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS. AND I ONLY
WHERE I IS THAT THE WORKER UT
WHAT I JUST DO NOT HAVE TO MEET
ONLY AT TO THE. THANK YOU. JUST
A REMINDER TAKING NINE NAME OF
HIS ON THE BILL THANK YOU. A
LINE SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CAN THOUSAND NATIONAL
OF THOSE WORKERS CALIFORNIA
INTO. THANK YOU. LINE ONE OF
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO THANK
THEY'VE DROPPED OUT OF THE
QUEUE. AT THIS TIME THERE ARE
NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU- AT THIS
POINT WILL MOVE ON TO-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- WE HAD
A LEAD WITNESS SCHEDULED TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION BUT WE
LEARNED EARLIER TODAY THAT THE
WITNESS FROM. THE CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES FOR NURSING HOME
REFORM- COULD NOT MAKE IT THEIR
POSITION IS LISTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WE WILL OPEN
IT UP TO PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION BEGINNING IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SAM NUNN.
OF ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NONE
THERE'S WHILE AND WE'RE MOVING
ON TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE IN THOSE WAITING
TO OPERATE PUBLIC COME IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- ONCE
AGAIN A REMINDER NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL. AND NOW IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. OF LIKE
TO BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND WE DEFENDER PAN.
THE BILL. IT WE HAVE A LOT AND
A SIMILAR ONE WHICH ELECTRICAL
I THINK I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. OKAY AND- CONSULTING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON MEASURE.
AB FOREIGN NINE BY RE. THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY HER TADO I. ALTHOUGH
I JONES CORTESE HI CORTESE I.
COM LONGER AYE FONG LONGER I'D
PAN HI ANNA CAN I. WE WILL
PLACES BELONG CALL THANK YOU.
AND OF NOT WE HAVE A JACK ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AND THE A BIG FIVE
NINETY BY SOMEONE FREED AND- WE
ARE READY FOR YOU. WHENEVER YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I THINK THAT WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT FOSTER YOU OR
SOME OF OUR DISTANT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS THEY WERE MUCH HIGHER
RATE OF HOMELESSNESS OF ENDING
UP INCARCERATED AND OF COURSE
THEY ARE VERY OFTEN THE VICTIMS
OF MULTIPLE TRAUMAS. CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THE FIRST STATES TO
OPT INTO THE FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE EXTENDED
FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAM BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN OVER THE PAST
ELEVEN YEARS WE'VE SEEN THAT
THE PROGRAM HAS WORKED VERY
WELL IT'S IMPROVE THE EDUCATION
AND EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES OF
FOSTER YOUTH AS WELL AS
REDUCING THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND WE'VE MADE CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM TO BETTER MEET THE
NEEDS OF TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
HOUSING WHICH STILL REMAINS
VERY CHALLENGING FOR FOSTER
YOUTH AS THEY OFTEN DON'T HAVE
ANYONE TO HELP THEM. WELCOMING
AND SUPPORTING HER AND SUPPORT
OF HOUSING PLAYS A CRUCIAL ROLE
IN PROTECTING THE SAFETY OF ALL
YOUTH. PARTICULARLY YOUTH
IDENTIFYING AS LGBT Q. AND
SUPPORTING AFFIRMING THEIR SELF
IDENTITY AND THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH ADULTS AND
PEERS. AB FIVE NINETY TWO
PROMOTES PLACEMENT STABILITY
AND A POSITIVE SUPPORTED
TRANSITION INDEPENDENCE FOR
YOUTH PARTICIPATING. IN THE
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE PROGRAM.
BY RESTRUCTURING THE HOST OF
FAMILY TRANSITIONAL HOUSING
MODEL TO ALLOW FOR GREATER
FLEXIBILITY. IN PROVIDING
TARGETED SAFE AND APPROPRIATE
HOUSING AND SUPPORT. TO YOUNG
ADULTS NEED ADDITIONAL
SERVICES. THE BILL'S RECEIVED.
BY A BROAD BI PARTISAN SUPPORT
AND THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I
REQUEST WE REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND- FROM. TO WANTED
TO- ARE. TAKEN COMMITTEES OF ON
THE ON THE STUFF WE WILL OKAY
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE A LEADER
SUMMER CAN LUIS ON THE CALL.
YES AFTERNOON CAN LIVE
REPRESENTING THE CAL CO FOR ONE
THE COUPON THE AB FIVE NINETY
YOU. I AM A WITH BANK ASSEMBLY
FRIEDMAN BURKE. COMMENTS- AN
THIS BILL PERMANENT PLACEMENT
ABILITY AND A PA OF TRANSIT AND-
ARE YOU. PARTICIPATE IN THE
EXTENT DOCTOR CARE PROGRAM. AND
HAVING OF ONLY HIGH THE NEED TO
THINK. ABOUT WHAT THOSE
POSITIVES THE OF HAVING SHOULD
BE VERY PEOPLE EXTENT CARE.
BILL EXPANDS AVAILABLE OP VERY
PEOPLE. TO HELP BEST THEIR
NEEDS ESPECIALLY FOR OUR YOUTH
COLOR AND HELP. YEAR I'M I'LL
JUST IT BRIEF WE HAVE
BIPARTISAN. AND NOT THAT I'M
AVAILABLE ANSWER QUESTIONS THEY
WERE. ASK YOUR AYE THAT THANK
YOU. HERE SHE DID A GREAT JOB
OF EXPLAINING JUST HOW
IMPORTANT OPTIONS ARE TODAY.
SUBPOPULATION AND THEIR YOUTH
IN FOSTER CARE. THOSE WHO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM MORE SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES THAN A PLACEMENT WITH
AT THE CLINIC CARE COVER EIGHTY
FIVE NINETY TO MAXIMIZE
DEVELOPER TRANSITION AQ COULD
BETTER EQUIPPED THAN A CHEATING
THEIR EDUCATIONAL AND CAREER
GOALS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IF YOU CAN EXPECT AFTER
CARE AND. SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
BEFORE YOU. THANK YOU- AT THE
SMALL MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENTED
SUPPORT BEGIN IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. C. NINE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. NINE THERE AND NOW
MOVING ON TO TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
NINETY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. N. ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. YOU CURRENTLY
HAVE THREE INDIVIDUALS IN OUR
QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH LINE
SEVENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
DANIEL ONE DRAW WITH CHILDREN
NOW IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON PICK ME BANNERGHATTA
CALIFORNIA COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATE ASSOCIATION OR
CALIFORNIA CASA IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE NINETY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOR PRACTICAL SALAS
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AT THIS
TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU- WE HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION
FOR THIS BILL BUT WILL MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
BEGIN IMPROVE FORTY TWO OR
THREE SEEN NONE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NINE THERE AS WELL- AND
I'LL MOVE ON TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. IF
YOU'RE NOW IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. TEN ONE ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO ONE IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. AND ABLE TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SINCE HER
PARENTS LIVE THE BILL THANK YU
HEY. WE HAVE A MOTION AND-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE WITH
SOMEONE OVER FRIEDMAN I
APPRECIATE THE HELP WITH THE
BILL AND I APPRECIATE ALL
SUPPORT THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU. OUR MOTION BY SENATOR PAN
AND CONSOLE TO KEEP PEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB FIVE NINE TWO BY
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO I.
FURTADO AYE JONES. CORTESE
RIGHT. CORTESE I COM LONGER.
COM LONGER AYE PAN RIGHT AND I.
THINK WE WILL PLACES BELONG
CALL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE IS
ON HIS WAY. UP NEXT WE HAVE
AGENDA ITEM ELEVEN AB.
EIGHT
ZERO EIGHT. HELLO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE WE ARE-
READY FOR YOU TO PRESENT AB
EIGHT ZERO EIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BOETTICHER MEMBERS
EIGHTY EIGHT OH EIGHT IS. HEY
CONTINUATION OF A LOT OF WORK
THAT HAS BEEN GOING ON OVER THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS LOOK AT
THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM HAND
TRYING TO. ENSURE THAT WE ARE.
LOOKING TOWARDS THE SUCCESS OF
THE KIDS IN THE SYSTEM. AND
MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
PLACEMENTS ARE APPROPRIATE AND
THE CONTINUING CARE REFORM
REALLY HAD FOCUSED ON S.
TEEPEES AND THERAPEUTIC TYPE
PLACE WITH BUT ONE OF THE GAPS.
THAT WE HAVE HAD IN THE SYSTEM
OR SOME OF THE KIDS WERE SEEN
AS THE HARDEST TO SERVE THAT
HAVE NEEDS BEYOND WHAT HAS BEEN
IN THE STATE. SO THE STATE HAS
IN COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE TO
CERTIFY PROGRAMS OUT OF STATE
TO SEND KIDS THAT THEY DIDN'T
FEEL WERE. ABLE TO BE SERVING
CALIFORNIA. BUT SYSTEM KINDA
CAME CRASHING DOWN LAST FALL
WHEN THE STATE DECERTIFIED ALL
OF THOSE OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES BROUGHT THE KIDS
HOME. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH EIGHT OH EIGHT. IS COULD
CREATE THAT CAPACITY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAPABILITY TO
SERVE ALL OF OUR KIDS NOW THIS
IS. ENDED UP BEING A VERY
COMPLEX SITUATION. AND BETTER
TRY IT REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF YOUR COMMITTEE HAS
DONE. A SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SO I'M VERY
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR AMENDMENTS.
THAT ARE LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND THE ONGOING WORK. TO
IDENTIFY SOME OF THE FUNDING.
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN PUT IN
PLACE WHAT AB EIGHT EIGHT AWAIT
REPRESENTS AND WHAT IT
REPRESENTS. IS A HIGHLY
ESSENTIALLY SORT OF PILOTS TO
PROVIDE SOME VERY HIGHLY
TAILORED INDIVIDUALIZED SERVICE
FOR SEVENTIES HIGH NEEDS KIDS
BUT THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
OFFERING IN HERE THAT THAT
WE'RE TAKING. DON'T JUST DO THE
PILOT FOR THE HIGH NEED KIDS
BUT ALL THE OTHER COMPONENTS TO
ENSURE THAT THOSE KIDS ARE NOT.
GOING TO BE PLACED IN THESE.
MORE RESTRICTIVE SETTINGS IN
THESE HIGHLY INDIVIDUALIZED
SETTINGS. WITHOUT A PLACE TO GO
SO THAT WE STEP DOWN AND STEP
AWAY FROM. THESE MUCH MORE
INTENSE SERVICES BECAUSE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THE KIDS ARE
HEADED TOWARDS FAMILY TYPE
PLACEMENTS WITH RESOURCE
FAMILIES AND IN PLACEMENTS THAT
THAT SERVE THEIR INTEREST THE
BEST BUT SOMETIMES WE NEED TO
GET THEM READY. SO THAT'S
REALLY WHAT AB EIGHT EIGHT
AWAIT IS ABOUT IT'S ADDRESSING
THE PROBLEM THAT HAPPENED WHEN
WE HAD THE DECERTIFY KIDS AND
THE FACT THAT WE SEND KIDS OUT
OF STATE. AT TIMES WHEN WE
PROBABLY SHOULD NOT BE DOING
THAT BECAUSE THE CLOSER KIDS
ARE HOME. THE BETTER THEY'RE
GOING TO BE THE MORE. THE
INDIVIDUALIZED PLACEMENT AND
THE THERAPEUTIC SETTING WITH
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND ALL
THE SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
THE MORE THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN.
INTENSELY IF NECESSARY AND THEN
STEP DOWN AND STEP AWAY FROM
THOSE MORE. RESTRICTIVE
INTENSIVE ENVIRONMENTS INTO
INDIVIDUALIZED PLACEMENTS INTO
A MORE FAMILY LIKE SETTING. IS
FOR THE BEST INTEREST OF THOSE
CHILDREN. THAT'S WHAT AB EIGHT
WAYS TO IT WERE ALSO TRACKING
LANGUAGE THROUGH BUDGET TRAILER
AND TALK WITH THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES AND A LOT OF FOLKS
TO LOOK AT HOW WE CAN FORM
TRANSFORM THE SYSTEM. TO MAKE
IT WORK BETTER FOR OUTCOMES FOR
KIDS THAT WE WERE DOING A LOT
TAKE A LOT OF AMENDMENTS THAT A
LOT OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER ASKED US
TO TAKE IN THIS OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THEY'VE BEEN RAISING OVER
THE TIME REALLY ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE. THE RIGHT KIND OF
REPORTING AND FEEDBACK ON THE
SYSTEMS SO THE KIDS ARE NOT
GETTING LOST WITHIN THE SYSTEM.
WE'RE ALSO ADDING A MORATORIUM.
IN THIS BILL ON SENDING KIDS
OUT OF STATE ON IT IT'S A
MORATORIUM ON. THE DEPARTMENT'S
ABILITY TO CERTIFY AT THE STATE
PLACEMENTS AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
HERE. ARE THERE IS SOMETHING
ACTUALLY THAT THE SENATE HAS
BEEN ASKING US TO DO SENATE
BUDGET HAS BEEN ASKING US TO DO
WE AGREED TO PUT THAT IN HERE.
AND I KNOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
WHO IS ONE OF THE SPONSORS. IS
NOT HAPPY WITH A MORATORIUM AND
I THINK THEY WILL ADDRESS THAT
COUNTY SAN EARLY WHEN SHE TALKS
WILL WILL ADDRESS THAT. I'M
FINE WITH THE MORATORIUM
BECAUSE IT MAKES IT PRETTY
CLEAR STATEMENT. THAT WE NEED
TO DEVELOP THIS CAPACITY IN
CALIFORNIA. TO THE BEST EXTENT
THAT WE CAN. I THINK THE
COUNTIES ARE APPROPRIATELY
CONCERNED RIGHT NOW. THAT AS WE
DEVELOP THE PILOT. WHICH IS
MEANT TO BE. THE REPLACEMENT
FOR THE OT OF STATE.
PLACEMENTS AS WE DEVELOP THAT
PILOT. WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO
WITH THE NEED. TO SERVE THESE
KIDS WE MIGHT HAVE TO BE
SENDING SOME OF THEM. OUT OF
STATE AND I THINK THAT IS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT CONCERN AT THIS
POINT. BUT I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT ON US. TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN O KEEP THOSE
KIDS IN STATE. DEVELOP THE
CAPACITY TO SERVE THEM. AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL POSSIBLE. WITH
APPROPRIATE SERVICES INCLUDING
THE MENTAL HEALTH PORTION. AND
I WILL ADMIT THAT THAT MENTAL
HEALTH PORTION WAS WHAT WE
STRUGGLED WITH WITH THE
CONTINUED CARE REFORM IS
GETTING THAT PIECE PUT IN.
BECAUSE THE NOTION WAS THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE. WE WERE
INSTEAD OF. PROVIDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AFTER DIAGNOSIS
IN DOWN THE ROAD WE WERE TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WILL PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES UP FRONT
FOR THESE KIDS. BECAUSE EVERY
KID COMING INTO CONTACT. WITH
AN AGENCY OR WITH A PROGRAM
LIKE THIS. IS SUBJECT TO TRAUMA
AND ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES IN ALL OF THESE
THINGS THAT. THAT SHOULD LEAD
US TO MAKE IT NATURAL THAT WE
WOULD PROVIDE. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES TO THEM. AND YET WE
HAVE STRUGGLED WITH THAT THAT'S
PART AND PARCEL TO THIS TO THE-
WHAT THE- PILOT IS FAR. LIKE
STA RT PEAS BUT MAYBE FOR ONE.
AND THEY ARE CO JOINED WITH
SIGNIFICANT MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES. WHICH FOR. NOW SO A
FOCUS OF THE ADMINISTRATION
WHICH IS A VERY GOOD THING. AND
IF WE CAN HELP THOSE KIDS IN
THAT SITUATION. WE CAN DEVELOP
THAT KEPT CAPACITY BETTER IN
CALIFORNIA ENSURE THAT WE HAVE
PLACEMENTS HERE. THAT'S WHAT AB
EIGHT AWAIT IS ABOUT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THE SITUATION THAT
WE FOUND LAST FALL WHEN THE
STATE HAD TO DECERTIFY ALL OF
THOSE OUT OF STATE PROGRAMS.
AND BUILDING THAT CAPACITY
HERE. NOW IF THROUGH THE BUDGET
MAKING APPROPRIATE INVESTMENTS.
IN THOSE KIDS IN THOSE PROGRAMS
GETTING THEM STABLE GETTING
THEM ABLE TO BE SENT OUT TO
RESOURCE FAMILIES AND THEY'RE
ALSO COMPONENTS WITH THIS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT. TWO GROW OUR
ABILITY CALIFORNIA TO RETAIN
RECRUIT. AND BRING THESE
RESOURCE FAMILIES. INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE THAT CAPACITY ACROSS
THE STATE. SO THAT THE HOT AND
I KNOW THAT HE VETO IT IS A LOT
BUT IT IS LONG PAST TIME WE
ADDRESS THIS IN CALIFORNIA. AND
BECAUSETHERE'S MONEY IN THE
BUDGET IN BECAUSE WERE WE HAD
THE NEED TO DE CERTIFY ALL OF
THOSE OUT OF STATE IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE THOSE
GAPS. MAKE SURE THOSE KIDS ARE
NOT SENT OUT OF STATE. MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THAT CAPACITY IN
CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS THOSE
NEEDS IN THESE OUR DEPENDENCY
KIDS. AND DELINQUENCY KIDS USER
ANY KID HOW IDEALLY WHO NEEDS
THE SERVICES OF PROTECTION AND
HELP. THAT'S WHAT EIGHT AWAIT
IS ABOUT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ITEMS. AT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE AYE WE- I
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THAT THE
PASSION YOU HAVE FOR- FOR OUR
FOSTER YOUTH AND YOU CAN TELL
IN YOUR IN YOUR OPENING
REMARKS- JUST TALK DEEPLY CARE
ABOUT THIS BUT- I TYPED
APPRECIATE THAT BUT FULHAM.
WANTED JUST TO EMPHASIZE THAT
IN AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO A LEAD
WITNESSES DO YOU HAVE ANY ON
THE CALL TODAY WE HAVE WE DO
KATHY SAID KNOWING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WILL FOR DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND HOPE CAME OVER
FROM THE SENECA FAMILY OF
AGENCIES. AND SENATE BECAUSE
ONE WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH A
TO DO. DEVICE THIS THIS PILOT
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
SOMETHING THAT IS DELIVERABLE
HERE. DO WE HAVE A GREAT THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY
OUTGO HEAD SORRY. NO GO AHEAD
THANK. EXCELLENT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CATHERINE MCDONALD WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF PATIENT DATA
MEDIA IS A CO SPONSOR OF EIGHTY
EIGHT AWAY OUR MEMBERS ALONG
WITH HER PROBATION COUNTERPARTS
WORKING EVERY DAY TO SECURE
SAFE AND SERVICE RICH PLACEMENT
FOR YOU WITH THE MOST COMPLEX
ME. DESPITE THE GREAT WORK THAT
HAS BEEN DONE UNDER THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM THE
HIGHEST END OF OUR SYSTEM HAS
NOT YET BEEN DOLED OUT BY THE
STATE WE SPONSORED EIGHTY
TWENTY EIGHTY THREE BY A FAMILY
MEMBER COOLEY IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN PROGRESS THE NEEDS OF
YOUR COSTA ISSUE BUT IT WAS
ONLY A PARTIAL POLLUTION. THAT
DON'T REQUIRE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO IDENTIFY GAPS
AND PLACEMENT CERVANTES AND
RECOMMEND MEASURES TO FILL THAT
GAP THE WORKING EIGHTY TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE S. AND GET
COMPLETE UNFORTUNATELY AND IT
IS OVERKILL BUT THE NEED IS
GROWING STATE IN A WAY TO HELP
SPREAD BILL THE BRIDGE MY
CURRENT SERVICES AND SUPPORT
FOR YOU COMPLEX NEED. TO THOUGH
THE ANTICIPATED. EIGHTY TWENTY
EIGHTY THREE RECOMMENDATIONS.
WELL WE ARE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE BELLY NOT RAISING THE-
CONCERNS AS YOU. ANTICIPATE
WHAT THE- AND I AT THE CREE A
BLANK JULY. MORATORIUM ON ALL
OUT OF THE- STEVE A FULLY
FUNDED AT OF THE BUDGET THE
SERVER IS UNDER A- EIGHT OH.
WALKING AVAILABLE WE'RE GOING
OUT AND THE NEXT TEN DAYS. WE
ARE. CONCERNED EVEN MORE USEFUL
UP IN A JUVENILE. LIVING IN A
COUNTY HIM SERVICES OFFICE. OR
WORK WORSE RIGHT AWAY AND END
UP ON THE STREET. TRAFFIC OR
OTHERWISE UNHARMED WAY. ALL OF
THESE ARE REAL I THINK THEY-
THAT APPLY TO WHAT WE TWENTY.
OF U. SCORCHER FROM OUT OF
STATE PLACEMENT. DURING THE
SUMMER OR- WHEN THEY WERE THE
CERTIFIED. IT ALL LACK OF
STAVING APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT
FOR THEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
DESPITE CHINESE BEST EFFORTS TO
FIND. STATE OF THE VEHICLE
RUNAWAYS AND NONE OF THEM WERE
IN JUVENILE HALL WHEN THEY'RE
OUT OF DATE. NONE OF THEM WERE
LIVING. IN OUR OFFICE. OUR
SYSTEM MUST ACT IN THE BEST AND-
OF THE TWO. WE ARE. STARTING
OFF ON HIS ABILITY TO MAKE A-
PLACEMENT OPTION AVAILABLE. IF
YOU. EVEN IF THEY ARE OUT OF
STATE IS INCOME OF THE WHAT
THEY BEST AND- WE HOPE TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE. YOU KNOW.
AND OF COURSE OUR OFF. AND HE
STAFF. TO LOOK AT THE SEASON
APPROACH TO ANY SORT OF MORE
TOWARD. BEGINS THE STATE AND
THE COUNTY TIME TO BUILD UP
THESE- WELL. CONSIDERING ABOUT
A THIRD OPTION ON IT YOU THANK
YOU BASIS. WHAT HIDING. AND
REPORTING. AND THE NEED. WE
AGREE WITH OUR OTHER THAT THE
STATE INTO DEVELOPING. BUT BOTH
THE TIME AND RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED TO DO THAT. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF OUR
POSITION WE ARE JUST. A PART ON
THE BILL AND ARE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
THE NEXT WE HAVE A HOPE CAME. A
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME
IS HEALTHCARE I'M A POLICY
ANALYST AT SENECA FAMILY OF
AGENCIES. UNDER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS SENATE HAD PROVIDED A
CONTINUUM OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES INCLUDING CRISIS
SERVICES TO NEEDS IN CALIFORNIA
WITH THE MOST COMPLEX AND
PERSISTENT HE REALLY HELPED ME.
AT IN THAT CABINET COMMITTED
UNCONDITIONALLY ANY CHILD OR
YOU REGARDLESS OF THEIR
PREVENTING BEHAVIOR. IN ORDER
TO DO THAT WE NEED THE TOOLS TO
INDIVIDUALIZED CARE TO EACH
CHILD. IN THE PAST AND HAVE
BEEN BUILT ON A LARGE SCALE
DEEP CREEK NINE INSTITUTION
BASED CARE. WE ARE BRINGING
KIDS TOGETHER WHO ARE
STRUGGLING PROFOUNDLY INTO ONE
PLACE. THAT DOESN'T WORK AND
KIDS DON'T GET BETTER. CONTINUA
QUE REFORM STARTED MOVE AWAY
THAT. THANK YOU THREE PART CARE
CONTINUE WHILE WE'RE MAKING
PROGRESS AND PARTS ONE AND TWO
EVER WHO CRISIS CRITICAL
CURRENTLY VERY AND BUILDING A
PLACE CPACITY WITH INTENSIVE
WITH THE FOSTER CARE. WHICH
WILL MAKE THE WITH THIRD PARTY
THE HIGH. HI CONTINUE THURSDAY
FOR YOUNG WHO ARE I. Q. CRISIS.
THE PILOT MY AN EIGHTY EIGHT OH
EIGHT ALLOWED HER TO BE SENT IN.
WHEN THEY'RE IN THE QUEUE
MOMENTS AND TRACK THEY CAN
ENVISION QUICK TO LET STRICT.
COMMUNITY AND HOME BASE
SETTINGS. I NEED HERE IN THE
LONG IF HELLO URGENT THEY'RE
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH PLACES FOR
EXPERIENCING OF SIGNIFICANT
EVERY A HAWKISH. TO GO IN.
WITHOUT HI CUTIE CAPTURE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO. AND THE NIGHT THE
EMERGING ROOM SLEEPOVER AND
WELL IS I THANK OUR ST.
BERKELEY AT SERVICE WHICH PLACE
THANK AND HAVE A AND TRAUMATIZE
CONT WITH. ONE WE MUST HAVE
OPTIONS. IT QUICKLY IN THE
UNTIL BASED CARE AB IT WILL BE
THE TOP. GET IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE C. NINE ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. AND THERE AND- WILL BE
GOING TO THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT LINE. FOR THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- PLEASE
REMEMBER TO CHANGE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY THANK YOU. THE
KEVIN AT THE COLUSA CALIFORNIA
WHAT'S RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS
THAT SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. EMLYN JUMPING ON THE PHONE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO VOICE
SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHT OH WAIT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
AT THE TIME WE DO HAVE TO IN
OUR QUEUE. WE'LL START WITH
LINE ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL
SANCHEZ ON THE AFTER THE G.
PROBATION OFFICERS- WE ARE CO
SPONSOR OF EIGHTY EIGHT AWAIT
IMPORTANCE PILOT TO BUILD UP
IMPORTANT PLACEMENT TO SERVICES
I WOULD JUST BRIEFLY NOTE THAT
WE DO HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT IMPOSING THE MORATORIUM
PRIOR TO IMPLEMENTING EIGHTY
EIGHT OH EIGHT AND THE ABILITY
TO BUILD OUT THE NECESSARY
INTAKE CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF OUR YOUTH. I WE
CERTAINLY REMAIN COMMITTED TO
INSURING CALIFORNIA HAS THE
NECESSARY RESIDENTIAL SERVICES
TO ENSURE ABOUT THE WELLNESS.
HM ARGUE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YEAH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
POLYURETHANE HALF OF THE COUNTY
OF FRESNO AND THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO BOTH IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. AT THIS MOMENT- WE
ARE MOVING ON TO THE LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AND WE HAVE- WITNESS
NUMBER ONE MARIA RESSA RUMMY
VIA TELEPHONE WITH THE VIEW TO
LAW CENTER AND- IF SHE'S ON THE
CALL YOU ARE FAT THREE MINUTES
TO PROVIDE THE TESTIMONY. BOB
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
MORNING ALL ON THE RIVER NEW
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY FOR THE
YOUTH LAW CENTER. AN
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS STATEWIDE
AND ACROSS THE NATION. THE
TRANSFORM CHILD WELFARE AND
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM SO THAT
CHILDREN IMPACTED BY THE SYSTEM
BOB. THANK YOU FOR. YOUR POST
ZERO BECAUSE OF CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LACK OF SAFEGUARDS TO KEEP
FOSTER YOUTH IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE SETTING INCLUDING
KEEPING KEEPING YOU DANCING.
BLACK A POSITION SUPPORTS TO
KEEP FOSTER YOUTH AND FAMILY
THE LACK OF INPUT FROM THE
DIVERSITY OF STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDING IMPACTED YOU CAN
FAMILIES. AND A LACK OF FUNDING
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OTHER
MEASURES TO EVALUATE
IMPLEMENTATION AFFECT THE
MINUTES AND THE IMPACT THE BILL
ON HEALTH SAFETY AND WELLBEING
OUTCOMES FOR FOSTER YOUTH.
THERE ABOUT THE PROPOSED PILOT
PROGRAM. YEAH WORKING WITH THE
OFTEN DISPOSITIVE THAT OUR
CONCERN ARE THE YOUTH LAWCENTER
IS PREPARED WITH. OPPOSITION BE.
GIVEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE THE
AUTHORS WILLING TO TAKE IN THE
COMMITTEE TO CREATE A
MORATORIUM ON SPENDING FOSTER
YOU OUT OF THE- PROVIDE OTHER
SAFEGUARDS TO PROTECT COST YOU
FROM UNNECESSARY RESPECT THE
PEOPLE THE PLACEMENT REPORT YOU
CAN FAMILY. INSURED WATER
STAKEHOLDER INPUT IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE PILOT
OPERATIONAL STANDARDS AND
ESTABLISH ACCOUNTABILITY INTHE
VALUE. OF THE VALUATION
MEASURES. I WANTED TO ASK THE
BE MORE TO HIM POSTED. KNOWS
THE MORE TOWARD ON THE USE
ARTIST FACILITIES FOR THE
PARKING POPULAR UPON YOU. WHILE
WE ARE TO. THIS NEW CONTINUES
TO SERVE- THERE'S YOU PROVIDE
THE CRITICAL SAFEGUARD
NECESSARY TO ENSURE THAT FOSTER
YOU ARE PROTECTED CAPSAICIN
HAVE THEIR NEEDS MET
APPROPRIATELY. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE CERTIFICATION WE ACT
LIKE THAT IS THAT WAS JUST A
FORMAL TECHNICAL THING MORE.
TWO DECADES OR MORE CALIFORNIA
HAS EXPERIENCED GAMBLE AFTER
SCANDAL OUT OF STATE FACILITIES
AND THE CERTIFICATION WHILE
THE- RESULT OF THE REVIEWING
THOSE FACILITIES. AND FINDING
THAT. WILL BE DID NOT MEET OUR
STATE FOR CARE OF CHILDREN
THANK WITH ALL THESE WERE NOT
SAFE OUR CHILDREN AND THE FACT
THAT WOULD BE THE OUT OF STATE
AND SO FAR AWAY IN THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE SO FAR AWAY FROM
FAMILIES AND PEOPLE THAT THEY
KNOW. IT DEMONSTRATED OVER THE
LAST TWO TO THREE DECADES THAT
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO POSITION WE
PROTECT YOUNG PEOPLE EMPIRE
STATE BUILDING. MORATORIUM IS
NECESSARY TO NOT ONLY BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE EXPRESS
INTENT OF THE GOAL TO PREVENT
OUT OF STATE PLATES THAT
HISTOLOGICAL. AND NECESSARY
COUNTERPOINT. BY A SPECIAL INTO
SERVICES WITH THE TO BUY TO
MEET THE OF ITS POP. OF FOSTER
YOUTH KNOW THE FATHER YOU WITH
HIGH ACUITY TO PREVIOUS WOULD
HAVE BEEN SENT OUT OF STATE.
YOU ARE ONE FACILITIES THE
SENSOR OF FRIDAY YOU- MAY THERE
MAY BEEN PROP WITH- FINDING
APPROPRIATE PLACEMENTS AND
MEANING THE NEEDS OF THOSE
YOU'D APPROPRIATELYBECAUSE OF
THE SHORT TIME FRAME THAT YOU-
CERTIFICATION IN TERMS OF
BRINGING YOU BACK QUICKLY. BUT
THESE ARE ALL SERVICES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY- CURRENTLY CANDIA
PROVIDED TO YOU IN THE STATE.
ARE IT IS THAT WE HAVEN'T
REALLY DEVELOPED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO DEVELOP THOSE
SERVICES SO THERE'S NO NEED TO
ALLOW FACILITIES ONCE AGAIN TO
BAMBOOZLE CALIFORNIA INTO
THINKING THAT WE ARE PROVIDING
SOME MEDICAL SERVICES. TO MEET
HIS NEEDS ARE WHEN IN FACT WHAT
THEY DO AND GAUGING THE VIEWS
THE PRACTICES AND DON'T PROVIDE
ANY SERVICES THAT MEET. THE
NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE OTHER
THAN BEING THE NEEDS TO BE A
DOLPHIN THE SYSTEM TO PLAY FROM
FAR AWAY AND HAVE BEEN
ESSENTIALLY LOCKED AWAY- WHERE.
THEY CAN'T. PHOTO OP THEY CAN'T
WHEN THEY'RE NOT BEING A. IN
CLOSING I JUST WANTED THAT THE
MORE IN THE OTHERS ARE IN ON.
MATHIS THERE CONSIDER WITH
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINUING OF CARE
REFORM AT KEEP CHILDREN WHICH
WAS SETTING RECORDS FOR OKAY.
MEMBERS ALSO PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITY BROADER. INPUT
ESTABLISHING. ARE IN THE
OPERATION STANDARD FOR THE-
INCLUDE PROVIDE GUIDE LINE. ARE
AROUND ELIGIBILITY STANDARDS
FOR RESPECT TO PLACE NEW
PADDING IN STATE LIMITING THE
LENGTH OF STAY. IN RESTRICTIVE
SETTINGS IN STATE PROVIDING
TRANSITION SUPPORTS TO KEEP YOU
CAN FAMILY SETTING. THANK YOU
SO MUCH SO I WILL CLOSE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND AT THIS
MOMENT WILL MOVE ON TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION-
BEGINNING A ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE SEE NON- WILL MOVE ON TO
ROUTE TWENTY FORTY WE HAVE
NUMBER AS WELL. I WILL OPEN UP
THE TELEPHONE A PUBLIC COMMENT
LINE FOR THOSE WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND
JUST A REMINDER UP TO STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY.
THANK YOU. IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
THERE IS CURRENTLY NO ONE IN
OUR QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE ONCE AGAIN
FOR- REALLY HIS YEARS OF WORK
TO BUILD COULD OF WITH THE
WHILE SYSTEM THAT IS FOR. TO
THE NEEDS THE SYSTEM INVOLVED
CHILDREN- THANK TO HIS
LEADERSHIP THIS AS OF ALL THE
WAY CON PLACE AND TORE MORE
FOR. BASED STUDY. WE NOW HAVE A
OF OUT OF PLACE OPTIONS DIDN'T
MEET THE RANGE OF NEEDS BY
SYSTEM INVOLVED. HOWEVER THE
KERN STRUCTURE IS NOT
SUFFICIENT TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
SOME CHILDREN WITH COMPLEX
MENTAL OR BEFORE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH NEEDS. AND IN THE PAST
SOME COUNTIES HAVE RELIED ON
OUT OF STATE PLACEMENTS FOR
THESE CHILDREN AS PREVIOUSLY
NOTED- SHOCKING REPORTS OF
CHILDREN. A CHILD. MULCH AND
EVEN THE DEATH OF THE CHILD.
AND THESE ARE THE STATE
PLACEMENTS HAS RAISED ALARMS
THROUGHOUT THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. IN RESPONSE A HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT FOSTER CHILDREN
WHO WERE PLACED IN OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES HAVE RETURNED. TO
CALIFORNIA AN NOW HAVE IN
STATE PLACEMENTS. THUS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE NO FOSTER
CHILDREN PLACED IN OUT OF STATE
GROUP HOMES. THIS BILL PROPOSES
TO FURTHER EXPAND IN STATE
PLACEMENT OPTIONS BY CREATING
NEW SPECIALIZED FOSTER HOMES
AND A- AND A CHILDREN'S CRISIS
CONTINUE A PILOT PROGRAM
INTENDED TO MEET THE COMPLEX-
MENTAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF THOSE FOSTER YOUTH. AT AND
COUNTIES TO HAVE THE GREATEST
CHALLENGE CHALLENGES PLACING.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WILL
CREATE A MORATORIUM ON OUT OF
STATE PLACEMENTS AS IS
NECESSARY TO ENSURE OUR MOST
WINNABLE CHILDREN ARE. NO
LONGER PLACED IN HARM'S WAY
WILL IN FACILITIES ARE. THAT
ARE FAR AWAY FROM THE A
PROTECTIONS CREATED FOR AND
STATE PLACEMENT I UNDERSTAND WE
HAVE OPPOSITION TO THE-
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND
ALTHOUGH I APPRECIATE THE
COUNTIES CONCERNS. THAT MORE
TIME IS NEEDED BEFORE OUT OF
STATE PLACEMENTS CAN BE STOPPED
I CONTINUED TO FEEL AS- THE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE- THAT I
CANNOT SUPPORT ANY PLACEMENT OF
CHILDREN IN OUT OF STATE CARE
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY. TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY OF THESE
YOUTH AND THEREFORE WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AND ALSO-
LIKE TO PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO. OUR COMMITTEE- MEMBERS TO
PROVIDE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ON THIS BILL AND- I HAVE AT
THIS TIME. SENATE QUARTERS HE
AND THEN FOLLOWED BY CENTER
PATH. AND THEN CENTER COME. ON
EARTH. THANK YOU IN I'M SURE
AND- THANK YOU OFFER FREE
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA- MUCH
APPRECIATED I. AM SUPPORTIVE
AND I AND I UNDERSTAND- THE
ISSUES- AROUND OUR STATE
PLACEMENT IN THE ATTEMPT TO
CORRECT THE ERROR. I'M JUST
CURIOUS BECAUSE A BILL. IT WAS
IN WOULD HELP OTHER- WHAT I
WOULD CALL KIND OF CASCADING
EFFECT ON THE CONTINUUM. IN MY
RECENT EXPERIENCE APART FROM
THE SENATE- INFORMED ME THAT
THE EARLY- DAYS ON THE
CONTINUUM IN TERMS OF
PLACEMENT- ARE ARE PROBLEMATIC
AND I'M JUST WONDERING IF YOU
COULD BRIEFLY INDICATE WHETHER
OR NOT THIS BILL WILL NOT THIS
BILL BECAUSE OF A SPECIALIZED-
THE SPECIALIZED. DEVELOPMENT A
SPECIALIZED FOSTER CARE
BASEMENT- IF IT'S IF IT'S YOUR
INTENT OR YOUR YOUR VISION WITH
THIS BILL THAT THAT WILL HELP
ON THE FRONT END OF THE
PLACEMENT PROCESS AS AS KIDS
ARE- ESSENTIALLY TAKING HIM. AT
INTAKE- IT IS IT IS AGAIN MY
EXPERIENCE THAT THOSE EARLY
DAYS- OFTENTIMES TURN INTO MORE
THAN DAYS AND IT TURNED INTO A
PROBLEMATIC PERIOD ON THE
CONTINUE- YES SHORT ANSWERS.
YES OR NO WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
THE INTENT OF THE BILL THE
IMPACT THAT IS FINE AND IT IS
IT IS. BUT REALIZED THAT THEY
CONSIST WHAT WE STRUGGLE WITH
WITH CONTINUE IT WAS WAS IT WAS
DESIGNED FOR TO CREATE A
THERAPEUTIC LEVEL. WITH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES UP FRONT AND
THAT'S BEEN THE STRUGGLE AND A
LOT OF THIS TIER T. P.'S. WORKS
TAKING SOME OF THE KIDS WITH
HIGH SECURITY. AND THAT'S WHY A
LOT OF THEM WERE LED TO THE
COUNTIES WERE TRYING TO FIND
PLACEMENTS FOR THEM. AND WE'RE
SENDING THEM OUT OF STATE
REMEMBER THE OUT OF STATE
FACILITIES ARE NOT LICENSED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEIR
LICENSE BY THEIR HOME STATE.
THEY'RE JUST CERTIFIED BY THE
STATE THANK AND CURRENTLY THERE
ANDBELIEVE THERE ARE NO
CERTIFIED OUT OF STATE.
PLACEMENTS AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW.
BUT THERE'S NOTHING THAT
PRECLUDES SHORT THE MORATORIUM
THE STATE FROM LICENSING THEM.
SO WHAT WE FOUND WAS AN
INCONSISTENT APPLICATION OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. AND
ESTHER TO SHORT TERM
RESIDENTIAL THERAPEUTIC.
PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTIES NOT
ALWAYS WILLING TO TAKE SOME OF
THE KIDS WITH THE HIGH
SECURITY. SO YES S. KIDS COME
IN IF THEY'RE EXHIBITING THOSE
HI CUTIE CHALLENGES. THERE WAS
A STRUGGLE LOCALLY TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE TO PLACE THEM THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS.
BUT TEY'RE STILL WILL REMAIN
SOME CHALLENGES ON GOING AND I
HAVE ANOTHER BILL THAT'S MOVING
THROUGH WE'RE WE'RE CONTINUALLY
WORKING. ON ON THE DRESSING
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES WITH
THE CONTAINMENT CARE REFORM. IN
LESS CONTROVERSIAL SETTINGS
THIS IS A THIS IS A MAJOR STEP
SO YES IT IS INTENDED TO TRY TO
ENSURE THAT WE THAT WE HAVE A
BROADER RANGE OF PLACEMENTS FOR
KIDS. ESPECIALLY ONES THAT HAVE
BEEN HARDER TO PLACE. AS THEY
WERE IDENTIFIED AND BROUGHT IN
BROUGHT INTO THE SYSTEM BOTH
DEPENDENCY AND DELINQUENCY MORE
TRYING TO FIND PLACES. FOR KIDS
TO GO. THAT SERVE THEIR NEEDS
SO THIS IS A MISSING COMPONENT
THIS IS A GAP THAT I THINK WAS
GOING TO BE SHOWN WITH THE GAPS
ANALYSIS THAT THAT. DEPARTMENT
WAS DOING BUT IS LATE IN
PROVIDING- WE'RE JUST.
TIMELINE'S MOVED UP BECAUSE THE
SITUATION WE FOUND OURSELVES IN
WITH THE DECERTIFICATION SO
YEAH THIS IS INTENDED. TO HELP
WITH THAT BUT AS A COMPLETE
ANSWER NO WE ARE GOING TO
STRUGGLE WITH IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES AND CONTINUE TO AND
THAT'S ACTUALLY NOT A BAD
THING. BECAUSE ANY SYSTEM IT'S
LARGER COMPLEXES THIS IF WE'RE
NOT CONSTANTLY LOOKING AT
TAKING FEEDBACK. LOOKING AT
DATA LOOKING AT WHAT HAPPENED
TO THOSE KIDS THEN WE'RE GOING
TO FIND OURSELVES IN THE SAME
SITUATION OF A REFORM THAT
NEEDED TO BE REFORMED BECAUSE
KIDS WILL BE DROPPING TO THE
CRACK. SO IT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IT AND THEN WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING THROUGH
THE COMMITTEE. AND TO BUDGET
STAFF AND ALL THESE OTHER
PLAYERS IS NOT JUST THE PILOT
BECAUSE WE CAN'T HAVE THE
PILOT. AND THIS IS WHERE THE
YOUTH LAWCENTERIS TALKING
ABOUT. THAT WHAT THEY WERE
ALARMED ABOUT. HOPE IT LEASE IT
WHAT WE DO IS THE PILOT. AND
THERE'S NO PLACE TO TAKE THESE
HIGH ACUITY KIDS AND STEP THEM
DOWN INTO BETTER PLACEMENTS
THAT ARE SERVING THEIR NEEDS.
THEN WE HAVE RESTRICTIVE AND WE
HAVE LESS RESTRICTIVE AND
THERE'S JUST NO BROADER PLAN.
SO THAT'S WHY THIS HAS BECOME
COMPLEX. BUT IT NEEDS TO BE
COMPLEX OTHERWISE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO BE SERVING ALL THE
KIDS. SO WHAT BABY MORE LOOKING
FOR IN THAT BUT YEAH THIS IS
NOT AN EASY THING BUT WE HAVE
SUCH AN OPPORTUNITY NOW HERE TO
CLOSE SOME OF THESE GAPS. AND A
LOOK AT KIDS AT THE HIGHER AND
GET THEM THE SERVICES THEY NEED
AND WHAT THE IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THIS IS. IS IF
THEY'RE GOING TO BE IN THAT
HIGH. ACUITY SERVICE LEVEL.
THAT WITHIN STEPPING THEM DOWN
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. BECAUSE
THAT MEANS THAT THEY'RE-
ADDRESSING WHATEVER IT IS THEY
NEED TO ADDRESS. AND WE'RE
KEEPING THEM OUT OF THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE AND THE MOST
INTENSIVE SITUATIONS WHICH IN
WHICH IS GOOD FOR THEM TO START
OFF WITH THE HELP BUT NOT GOOD
FOR THEM LONG TERM. THANK YOU
YOUR I APPRECIATED THE RESPONSE
THANK YOU MARIA THE COMMISSION.
THANK YOU SENATOR CENTER PATH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ST RIVER-
STONE THAT FOR YOUR TREMENDOUS
WORKERS FOR MANY YEARS ON THE-
THE FORMS KHATOON CARE REFORMS
AND- CERTAINLY APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH-
WITH WITH THIS BILL- AND-
FRANKLY I DO AGREE WITH THE-
MORATORIUM IT'S A CHALLENGE
BUT- FRANKLY I'M NOT SURE ANY
OTHER STATE DOES IT ANY BETTER
AND SO BY SIMPLY SHIPPING THEM
OUT IT'S ALMOST LIKE OUT OF
SIGHT OUT OF MIND. BECAUSE AND
I THINK WE FOUND OUT AS WE
ACTUALLY LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING
ON YOU DON'T REALLY DOING ANY
BETTER NOW THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT WE'RE DOING THAT WE
COULDN'T DO BETTER ALSO AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO BUILD THE CAPACITY INCLUDING
THE PILOTS. I GUESS THE
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU IS
THAT- ULTIMATELY- I'M- ASSUMING
THAT THE PILOTS OR SUCCESSFUL
OR THAT. ANY AT SOME POINT TIME
WE'VE HAD- PEOPLE. DO SO THAT'S
WHY. I'M A PEDIATRICIAN I TOOK
CARE OF THE CHILDREN WITH
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES- INCLUDING
MANY FOSTER CHILDREN AND- SOME
OF THEM CAN BE EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING. RIGHT THERE IN
SITUATIONS AND- CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT WE SHOULD TRY
TO KEEP SOME OF THE LATE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE. AT THE SAME TIME
THERE ARE NO AT LEAST A CERTAIN
POINTS IN TIME AND- BEHAVIOR
ORDER SECURE CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE THEY REALLY DO NEED
INTENSIVE. CARE AND- SO SOUNDS
LIKE WHAT WE DID IS THAT WE
SAID WELL YOU KNOW WHAT. IF
THERE'S- THE REALLY INTENSIVE.
WE'RE NAMING IT TAKE THEM INTO
OUR OWN STR DURING OUR OWN
SHORT TERM STR T. P.'S RIGHT.
WHAT'S GONNA SHIP THEM OUT
SOMEWHERE. HER EIGHT AND NOW
WILL SAY YOU CAN'T DO THAT. IT
YOU DO YOU THINK WE TOOK WHERE
ACTUALLY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE GONNA SAY YOU KNOW NO
MATTER HOW DIFFICULT THEY ARE.
GONNA FIND A WAY TAKE CARE OF
THEM SOMETIMES THE RESULTS ARE
YOU KNOW THEY TAKE TIME IT'S
YOUNG IT'S NOT THERE'S NO MAGIC
BULLET TO KNOW TREATING SOMEONE
THAT'S ONLY TAKES A CHILD TO.
HAVE GIVEN A CERTAIN SET OF
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THE TRAUMA
THE EXPERIENCE IN THE MIDDLE
HEALTH ISSUES THAT. EVEN WITH
THE BEST OF CARE THAT THEY'RE
INSTANTLY EVERYTHING'S GONNA BE
PERFECTLY FINE FOR THEM RIGHT
AT THAT. TREATMENT TAKES TIME
IT TAKES EFFORT. EVEN WITH A
HIGH PERCENTAGE OF HIS
SUCCESSOR STILL FRACTION AND
AREN'T SO SUCCESSFUL- THAT BUT
I ALSO SORT OF YOU AND YOU
PLEASE CORRECT ME IF YOU THINK
THAT YOU THINK FEEL DIFFERENTLY
OR THINK I'M WRONG. IS THAT TO
CERTAIN EXTENT PART OF THE
REASON WE GOT TO WHERE WE
GOTTEN AND WHAT YOUR AND I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
SOMEONE ADDRESSING THE BILL IS
THAT. OF THE ONE WHO REALLY
NEED INTENSIVE CARE WE'RE-
WE'RE WE'RE ALMOST A LITTLE
FRAYED TO TAKE CARE OF THEM
THAT WHAT HAPPENED IS OKAY FINE
WE'LL REFER THEM SOMEWHERE ELSE
INSTEAD OF ACTUALLY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HERE. AND AND I ALSO
APPRECIATE WITH THE PILOT THAT
STILL DOESN'T MEAN WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TAKE CARE OF ALL OF
THEM- BUT HOPEFULLY- WE CAN GET
TO THAT PLACE- BUT- TO I GUESS
AND THEN TRY TO QUESTIONS THAT
RATE CLEAR BUT AT SOME SOME
POINT TIME WE HAVE TO SAY IS A
SYSTEM- WE- MATTER HOW.
DIFFICULT IT MAY BE TO TAKE
CARE OF SOME OF THE D. THEFT AT
THAT AT A PARTICULAR
CIRCUMSTANCE AGAIN AND AGREE
WITH THE HELP DESK BUT YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S- THAT. WITH THAT
WE DON'T JUST SHIP THEM OUT
SOMEWHERE WE HAVE TO SOMEHOW
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY AND SAY
YES WE'RE GOING TO JUST DO THE
BEST WE CAN. TO TAKE CARE OF
THEM DOES THAT MAKE SENSE- ARE
TODAY HE DOES IT YEAH. THIS IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE DOING. THAT
IT'S A PILOT FOR A COUPLE
REASONS. ONE OF WHICH SAID THIS
THIS IS. DON'T TALK ABOUT THIS
THIS IS A SECRET. WHAT ARE THE
REASONS THAT THE PILOT IS
BECAUSE WE'RE WORKING THROUGH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THEY LIKE
PILOTS NOT PERMITTED SETTING
THE OTHER REASONS PILOT. IS TO
ENSURE AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
RECOGNIZE. THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO FEED. THE NEED TO BE
TESTING AND ENSURING THAT WHAT
WE'RE DOING. WORKS BECAUSE WE
JUST SET SOMETHING UP AND SAY
WE'RE DONE RIGHT THERE'S NO.
THERE'S NONE OF THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY THERE'S NONE OF
THAT MAKING SURE WE DID THE
RIGHT THING. AND IF THIS IS
GOING TO MORPH OVER TIME I
THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING IN
THIS CASE BECAUSE IT MEANS THAT
WE'RE LISTENING TO OURSELVES
AND WE'RE LOOKING WHAT THE
OUTCOMES ARE. GREAT SO THAT'S
KIND OF WHY. WE TALKED ABOUT IT
IT IT SORT OF SEEMS A PILOT BUT
IT IS THIS WORKS YEAH WE'RE
LOOKING AT. INTENSIVE SERVICES
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE THAT
CAPACITY WE DID JUST SEND THEM
OUT AND BECAUSE WE JUST WE
WEREN'T ABLE TO SERVE THEM HERE
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE WILLINGNESS
AND A LOT OF THOSE OTHER
COMPONENTS WORK MORE QUITE
WORKING THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO. THERE WERE
NOT ABOUT THAT MANY KIDS THAT
NEED THAT HELLO HIGH LEVELS OF
SERVICES AND ONE OF MY FEARS.
IS THAT IF WE CREATE. THESE
BETS THE- THERE ARE HIGH LEVEL
BEDS THAT ARE EXPENSIVE. THEN
WE CREATE THE DESIRE TO
CONTINUE TO FILL THEM ALL THE
TIME. WELL THAT'S OVER KILLING
WE'RE PUTTING KIDS IN
SITUATIONS THEY DON'T NEED THAT
IS NOT GOOD FOR THEM. IF WE SET
IT UP WITH THE STEP DOWNS IN
THIS CONCERT REVIEW. THEN THE
SYSTEM IS REALLY SET UP TO TEN
NOT NECESSARILY FILL THOSE BEDS
BUT MAKE SURE WERE.
APPROPRIATELY PLACING KIDS SO
THOSE KIDS WHO NEED LONGER
SERVICES. CAN GET THEM. AND THE
KIDS WHO DONALD PARTS STOCK IN
THAT. THEN THE FLIP SIDE TO
THIS AND WHERE THE- THE WILL
FOR DIRECTORS IN THE- PROBATION
SHE'S ARE CORRECT. WE BROUGHT
THOSE KIDS BACK AND THEY GOT
PLACE. BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ACTUAL DISTANCE STATISTICS THE
NUMBER OF KIDS WHO ARE A WALL
AT WAR WHO WENT BACK INTO
JUVENILE HALL. THAT LEVEL OF
THE PERCENTAGES OF THOSE KIDS
WE BROUGHT BACK. NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SO WE HAVE TO AND WHETHER
REASONS THAT THAT I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF A MORATORIUM.
ALTHOUGH I AM SENSITIVE TO MY
SPONSORS BELIEVE YOU ME ON THIS.
BUT WE HAVE TO LIGHT A FIRE AND
WE HAVE TO PUSH HARD TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THIS WORK DONE. WE
HAVE MONEY NOW IN THE STATE WE
HAVE THE MOMENTUM IN SOME
IMPETUS. LET'S TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THAT AND IF ALL WE DO IS
KICKED THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD.
AND THEN ASK THE DEPARTMENT TO
DO MORE CERTIFICATIONS OF OUT
OF STATE FACILITIES WHERE WE
DON'T HAVE THE CONTROL WE DON'T
HAVE THE INSIGHT WE DON'T HAVE
THE OVERSIGHT. WE'RE GONNA END
UP BACK WITH THE SAME SCANDALS
SO LET'S TRY THIS A LITTLE BIT
HARDER. THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF THOSE KIDS AND
FROM A PEDIATRICIAN STANDPOINT.
WHEN WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
EARLY IDENTIFICATION OF
DEVELOPMENT DELAYS AND
CHALLENGES FOR KIDS. A LOT OF
PHYSICIANS PUSH BACK AND THEIR
PUSH BACK IS WE IDENTIFIED I
DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO REFER
THEM WE DON'T HAVE THE SERVICES.
SO IF WE HAVE THE SERVICES IF
WE BUILD THIS. IN WE CAN HELP
THOSE KIDS. AND WE NO LONGER
HAVE TO LOOK THE OTHER WAY SO
LET'S JUST DO THAT. I'M WORKING
FOR THE WITH THIS POPULATION
SPECIFICALLY DEPENDENCY
DELINQUENCY KIDS YES. BUT
THEY'RE ALSO A LOT OF.
DEVELOPMENT DISABLED KIDS AND
OTHERS WHAT WE DON'T KNOW
REALLY WHERE TO GO THEY GO OUT
OF STATE. LET'S LOOK AT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE. TAKE A HARD
LOOK AT THE SYSTEM. FOR
CALIFORNIA FOR CRYING OUT LOUD.
BURKE VERY LARGE STATE I DON'T
HAVE THE CAPACITY WE SHOULD BE
DOING ALL OF THAT HERE AND THIS
IS A STEP THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
TAKE IN THIS WAY WE NEED TO BE
DOING THIS NOW AND WE'RE DOING
HERE POLICY. RESIDENT BUDGET.
NO THANK THANK YOU AND I ALSO
SET ON THE BUDGETS OF THREE-
THE ON HEALTH AND EVEN SERVICE
SO SOFT TISSUE TO WORK AND-
CERTAINLY I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE THE CAPACITY
HERE. WE ARE BIG STATE THERE'S
NO REASON WE SHOULDN'T HAVE
THAT CAPACITY WE- DOLLAR SIZE
BIRD INGENUITY HERE AND
ACTUALLY FRANKLY THE LEVEL
SERVICES THAT WE- BELIEVE THAT
SHOULD BE DELIVERED SO- THANK
YOU AND I'LL BE HAPPY TO MOVE
TO BUILD APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR PAN US
SENATE CONGER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I AM. TO WILL BE
SUPPORTING- THIS BILL AND- I
AGREE WITH SENATOR PAM YOU KNOW
I'D- I ALSO SUPPORT A
MORATORIUM I THINK- YOU KNOW
WHAT WE LEARNED- ABOUT OUR OUT
OF STATE PLACEMENTS. INCREDIBLY
EGREGIOUS- AND REALLY SHOULD
NOT HAVE HAPPENED AND I
ACTUALLY BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
LIABLE FOR THE VIOLATIONS
AGAINST THOSE CHILDREN- AND THE
DEATH YOU KNOW I. I DON'T KNOW
IF I NECESSARILY AGREE THAT THE
LEAST AS RESTRICTIVE AS ALWAYS
THE BEST I THINK WE SHOULD BE
TRYING TO FOCUS ON A SETTINGS
AND PLACEMENTS THAT ARE SAFE
AND THAT ARE RESPONSIVE TO THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OF EACH CHILD.
I THINK WE'VE SORT OF GOTTEN
AWAY FROM FOSTER CARE JUST LIKE
WE'VE GOTTEN AWAY FROM OUR
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE WE PUT ALL
OF THESE FOLKS IN A BUCKET
THINKING THAT- THERE'S A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH THE
BIGGER THE NUMBER YOU KNOW THE
MORE THE MONEY THE MORE THE
BADS THE PROBLEM WILL BE
SOLVED. WITHOUT REALLY
RECOGNIZING THAT- EACH PERSON.
HAS INDIVIDUAL NEEDS.
INDIVIDUAL TRIGGERS AND NEEDS
AN INDIVIDUALIZED AND
CUSTOMIZED RESPONSE THAT IS
CONSISTENT- IN ORDER TO HELP
THEM THROUGH WHATEVER THE
CRISES IT IS THAT THEY HAVE.
AND I KNOW AS THE STATE EVEN AS
COUNTIES AND CITIES WERE
LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS THAT ARE
SCALABLE WITHOUT NECESSARILY
FOCUSING ON WHAT'S GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL FOR THAT PARTICULAR
PERSON. I RESPECT THE FACT THAT
THERE'S THOUGHTFULNESS TO THIS
AND I RESPECT THE FACT FACT
THAT. YOU'RE SAYING IT IS
COMPLEX THIS IS COMPLICATED AND
IT IS COMPLEX. AND TO COME UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
BE PERFECT RIGHT NOW. IF
SOMEONE SAID THAT I WOULD LOOK
AT THEM AND CROSS MY EYES- WE
SHOULD NOT BE THINKING ABOUT
DEVELOPING SOMETHING THAT'S
PERFECT RIGHT OUT OF THE GATE
SO I ACTUALLY SEE THIS AS- PART
OF THE BUILDING BLOCKS TO HOW
WE RE ENGINEER A SYSTEM. THAT
WORKS FOR ALL OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT WILL BE IN IT
RECOGNIZING THAT TAKES TIME
RECOGNIZING THERE PROBABLY WILL
BE SOME FALSE STARTS BUT THAT
IS WHEN YOU KNOW. THAT YOU ARE
WORKING TOWARDS SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE GOOD. BECAUSE YOU HAVE
KICKED THE TIRES YOU HAVE
BROUGHT IN STAKEHOLDERS YOU ARE
ADDRESSING THE SLIPS AND THE
FAILURES IN THE SETBACKS AND
YOU ARE REALLY WORKING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW YOU CAN CREATE A
LARGE SYSTEM. THAT SERVES
INDIVIDUAL KIDS IN A WAY THAT
MEETS THEIR INDIVIDUAL NEEDS SO
I SUPPORT THIS AND RECOGNIZE
THROUGH YOUR- PRESENTATION. HOW
DIFFICULT THIS HAS BEEN AND
JUST WANT TO SALUTE YOU FOR IT-
AND I TO WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU- SO
WHAT DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
PROBABLY THE BEST WAY TOO MUCH
I APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION AND
THIS IS JUST. WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY SOMETHING
SIGNIFICANT LET'S DO IT AND I
ASK FOR YOUR I. ABOUT. THANK
YOU SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PAN AND CANCEL TO KEEP
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB EIGHT
A. B. EIGHT OH EIGHT BY STONE
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST DEMAND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSE. HER TADO I FURTADO I'D
JONES. CORTESE I CORTES III COM
WALKER AND I COME LONGER AYE
PAN HI ANNA HI. THANK YOU
SENATORS WE WILL PLACE THAT
BELONGS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND UP NEXT WE HAVE AGENDA ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE- AB EIGHT TO NINE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND-
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU
ALREADY. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE. A I OFTEN TELL PEOPLE
THAT- LEGISLATION FOSTER YOUTH
IS OFTEN THE MOST CHALLENGING
WE HAVE IN THE LEGISLATURE SO I
REALLY APPRECIATED THE
DELIBERATION I WASN'T SURE IF
MR STONE OR YOU OUT OR YOU ARE
MISTER STONE OUTSIDE- IT CAME
IT CAME TO AN END AFTER I THINK
TWELVE ROUNDS- SO THANK YOU
AGAIN AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE WILL
SUPPORT UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE BY REQUIRING
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE. THE STATE
WITH INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
CAP FOSTER YOUTH WITH
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN I AUTHORED AB
NINE HUNDRED- WHICH WAS CALPERS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FEDERAL
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
STATUS A LOT WHICH WAS CREATED
HELP ABSURD ABUSED AND
NEGLECTED OR- OR NEGLECTED
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN OBTAIN A
LAWFUL. PERMANENCY RESIDENCY IN
THE UNITED STATES THIS RELIEF
IS DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN WITHOUT
LEGAL ASSISTANCE. AB EIGHT
TWENTY NINE WILL CREATE A
UNIFORM PROCESS TO IDENTIFY
UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER YOUTH. SO
THE STATE CAN BETTER PROVIDE.
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES
NECESSARY FOR THESE USED TO
SEEK LAWFUL RESIDENCY IN THE
UNITED STATES THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR AND WE
CAN BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST LEAD
WITNESS IN AND ACTORS FOR THE
PART OF THIS BILL- MUDDY CREWS
AND OTHER MIGHTINESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME IS
MERRY CHRISTMAS JOHNNY AND I AM
FORMALLY. UNDOCUMENTED FOLKS
USE I WAS BORN IN MEXICO AND
WAS BROUGHT TO THE UNITED
STATES WHEN I WAS ABOUT FIVE OR
SIX YEARS OLD. I ENJOY THE
FUNKY CARE WHAT OUR FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM WHEN I WAS FIFTEEN DUE
TO CONCERNS OF THE COLLECTOR. I
REMEMBER BEFORE I WAS IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM I WANTED TO
HAVE A JOB BUT I FOUND OUT I
NEEDED A SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
TO WORK. AND THAT I DIDN'T
CATCH IT WAS ONLY THEN THAT I
REALIZED. I WAS VERY.
UNDOCUMENTED PERSON A LITTLE
AFTER I ENTER FOSTER CARE MY
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKER CONNECTED
ME WITH SOMEONE WHO HELPED ME
OBTAIN A SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
JUVENILE PIZZA AND MY GREEN
CARD. I REMEMBER FEELING REALLY
HAPPY AND REALLY WHEN I GOT MY
GREEN CARD BECAUSE I KNEW HOW
MUCH A PERSON WITH NO SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER AND LOW
IMMIGRATION STATUS IN THE
COUNTRY STRUGGLES. TO MOVE OVER.
THEIR HEAD OR MOVE OUT OF
POVERTY. RIGHT NOW MAYBE THE
CARD EMIGRATE CARD. I GOT MY
FIRST JOB. IN I WILL WHICH
COULD MY FOR CAR. I HAD DEAL
BETWEEN TO REAP. AND CAN
POSSIBILITIES AND SILICON WORKS.
AND THEN I BILL I WANTED TO
LEAVE A TEAM OF PEOPLE TODAY I
EXPLORE DIFFERENT. OF AND
OPTION THAT I KNOW WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO. WITHOUT A GREEN CARD
INCLUDING MY CURRENT GOAL OF
BECOMING A DETECTIVE- NONE OF
THESE BECAUSE IF I DIDN'T HAVE
THE TIME. TWELVE FOR MAKING
pCARD AND THE DOORS OPENED. I AM
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TURN THE
CHALLENGING EXPERIENCES OF MY
YOU INTO SOMETHING GREAT. MY
SUCCESS STORY SHOULD BE ONLY
ONE OF MANY. IT IS MY HOPE THAT
A DOCUMENT TO YOU IN THE POCKET
CARE SYSTEM ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THE HELP I RECEIVED. SO THEY
TOO CAN OBTAIN IMMIGRATION
STATUS THEY QUALIFY FOR. AB
EIGHT NINE WOULD HELP ENSURE
FALSE YOU ARE LINKED TO THE
ASSISTANCE THEY NEED TO OBTAIN
IMMIGRATION STATUS AND
TRANSITION FOR COSTLY OUT OF
POCKET CHRIS THAT THEM. BECAUSE
OF THIS I'M HERE BECAUSE WE'RE.
GOING TO BILLS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TO. NOW WE
ARE MOVING ON LEAD WHAT THE
NUMBER TWO AT. A WHITE. MY NAME
IS KERRY WHITE AND I'M AN
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY WITH
CHILDREN FOX HUNTER CALIFORNIA.
HILTY OF THE NONPROFIT LEGAL
SERVICES ORGANIZATION THAT
SERVES AS THE VOICE IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM FOR
DEPENDENT CHILDREN AND GET. OUR
TRAINS AND OTHER PROFESSIONAL
STAFF REPRESENT OVER THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND ABUSED AND
NEGLECTED CILDREN IN THE LOS
ANGELES SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER
COUNTY FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. IN
ADDITION TO APPEARING ON BEHALF
OF CLIENTS AND DATED A
DEPENDENCY PROCEEDINGS. GLC
PROVIDES REPRESENTATION AND A
HOST OF RELATED HEARING THE
CHECK TO ENSURE THE WELL BEING
AND FUTURE SUCCESS OF EACH
CHILD. WE THINK IT'S SIMPLY
MEMBER LEVINE FOR AUTHORING
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
WHICH WILL ENSURE THERE ARE
PROCESSES IN PLACE TO PROTECT
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE. THE VAST MAJORITY OF
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN WHO ENTER
THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FORMS OF
IMMIGRATION RELIEF. THAT WOULD
PUT THEM ON A PATH TOWARDS
OBTAINING LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS ALSO KNOWN AS THE
GREEN CARD. CONGRESS RECOGNIZED
THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
VULNERABILITIES OF UNDOCUMENTED
AUSTRIA. AND IN RESPONSE
CREATED A SPECIFIC FORM OF
IMMIGRATION RELIEF FOR THE FEW.
WHO ARE UNABLE TO REUNIFY WITH
THE PARENT CALLED SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT JUVENILE STATUS.
WHICH IS ITSELF A PATH TOWARDS
BAKUL PERMANENT RESIDENCY. AND
DOCUMENTED CHILDREN WHO LEAVE
THE DEPENDENCY SYSTEM WITHOUT
OBTAINING SPECIAL IMMIGRANT
JUVENILE STATUS OR SOME OTHER
FOR IMMIGRATION RELIEF WILL BE
UNABLE TO LAWFULLY WORK OR
TRANSITION. SUCCESSFULLY TO
ADULTHOOD. HOWEVER THERE ARE NO
REQUIREMENTS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT THE ISSUES ARE IDENTIFIED
AND LINKED WITH IMMIGRATION
LEGAL SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
ASSIST THEM IN OBTAINING THAT
IMMIGRATION REALLY. AS A RESULT
THE LEVEL OF THE SYSTEM FOR YOU
TO RECEIVE ON THEIR IMMIGRATION
MATTER VERY FROM COUNTY TO
COUNTY. EMBOLDEN COUNTY SUCH AS
SACRAMENTO OUR LAWYERS ARE
TYPICALLY THE ONES SEARCHING
FOR IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY OR
NONPROFIT TO REPRESENT OUR
CLIENTS. COMPARISON AND LOS
ANGELES THE CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY CLOSELY WORKS THAT ARE
TRAINED TO IDENTIFY LOCAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND PRO
BONO ATTORNEYS WILL PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES FOR
OUR CLIENTS. WE HAVE ALSO HEARD
ACCOUNTS OF OTHER COUNTIES
WHERE NO IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES OR IN. ON OTHER
RESULTS YOU DO NOT RECEIVE THE
IMMIGRATION RELIEF TO WHICH
THEY ARE ENTITLED AND
EVENTUALLY LEAVE THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM WITHOUT IMMIGRATION
STATUS. UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN
IN THE PENALTY SYSTEM ALREADY
FACE A NUMBER OF HURDLES AT THE
WITH LITTLE TO NO INFORMATION
OR DOCUMENTATION ABOUT THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS. EVEN WHEN
THEY MAY BE AND REMOVAL OR
DEPORTATION PROCEEDINGS. EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE WILL REQUIRE
THAT COUNTY CHILD WELFARE
AGENCIES HAVE A PROCESS IN
PLACE TO IDENTIFY AND TRACK
UNDOCUMENTED COST YOU THEIR
COUNTY. IT WILL REQUIRE THAT
THE AGENCIES MAKE BEST EFFORTS
TO LINK THE CHILDREN
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS. AND IF NECESSARY
IDENTIFY ANY GAPS IN SERVICES
AND SUPPORT. ALL OF THESE
MEASURES ARE AIMED AT ENSURING
THAT UNDOCUMENTED AUSTRIAN YOU
NOT FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS.
ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
IMMIGRATION RELIEF FOR WHICH
THEY ARE SO FREQUENTLY ELIGIBLE
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU BOTH FOR YOUR A TESTIMONY
TODAY WILL MOVE ON TO A PUBLIC
COMMENT AND SUPPORT IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEE NON
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NO AND NO
ONE THERE ARE AND NOW WILL TAKE
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT ALAN THE
TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT MY.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
MODERATION AWARENESS ON THE
BILL ONLY. PALINDROMIC TURN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN IN OUR QUEUE. THEN
WE'LL START WITH LINE ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS ERIC HARRIS CALLING
FROM DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. PINE SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI DANIEL ONE DROUGHT
WITH CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BLIND SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE HAVE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA FROM. THANK YOU
KEVIN I'VE BEEN TOLD ME. SOME
OF THE ALL OF ME. THE KEVIN OF
THAT COALITION WHAT ARE SUPPORT
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME
AGAIN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
KEVIN. A LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. REBECA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION ACROSS
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. SHE. FINE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS PANEL
AGAINST REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FIND ONE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON COULD
MEET THERE ARE BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COSTA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE ONE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
TURN MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER
FROM NIELSEN MARK MURDER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT. ONE SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
MEMBERS PAUL YOU'RE A B. HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
SPORT THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER IN OUR
QUEUE PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
YOU AT THIS MOMENT ARE WE HAVE
NO LEAD UP BUT NO LEAD
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL- BUT WE
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL BEGIN
ROUTE FORTY TWO OR THREE. C.
NONE OF ROOM TWENTY TWENTY
FORTY. NUMBER AS WELL AND IT
WILL MOVE ON TO THE TELEPHONE
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE FOR THOSE
WAITING TO. PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL IN NAME ORGANIZATION OF
POSITIONALLY PLEASE. AND THOSE
ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. THERE'S
CURRENTLY NO ONE IN OUR QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. THANK
MODERATOR- CALLED THIS ONE WILL
TAKE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ONE OF 1% A
QUARTER CORTEZ HE FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR PAN- THINKING MA'AM
SURE- FIRST OF ALL- IF. THANK
YOU SO MEMBER FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND- IN THIS AREA AB
EIGHT NINE CERTAINLY CAME IN
HERE VERY SUPPORTIVE AND I JUST
I WAS TROUBLED. BY SOMETHING
THAT SEEMED TO CONTRADICT WHAT
I READ A LITTLE BIT- IN THE
ANALYSIS I'M WONDERING IF-
THROUGH THE CHAIR OF THE AUTHOR
THE LEAD WITNESS WOULD BE
WILLING TO RESPOND- DURING THE
TESTIMONY. A COUPLE OF TIMES SO
THE WITNESS TALK ABOUT TRACKING
AND IDENTIFYING- IN A LOT OF
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
ANALYSIS REALLY. TO MY COMFORT
GOES THE- WITH SORT OF IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION OF THE- YOU
KNOW ANY DATA WOULD BE DE
IDENTIFIED ON. AND IN LANGUAGE
SUCH AS THAT- REALLY MAKING IT-
SORT OF THE HELLO IS A
PERMISSIVE BUT IT SEEMS TO BE
INITIALLY WHEN I READ THE SAID
THE BILL WAS ESSENTIALLY TRYING
TO SAY- WHEN THAT INFORMATION
IS AVAILABLE TO THE AND I'M
SPEAKING TO THE COUNTY
PARTICULARLY AS OPPOSED TO
COMMITTEE BASE AGENCIES- WHEN
THAT INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE-
THAT- THE COUNTY WOULD DO THE
REFERRAL MAKE SURE TO DO THE
REFERRAL THE IMMIGRANT
SERVICES. SOME LITTLE CONCERN I
KNOW IN IN MY HOME COUNTY SANTA
CLARA COUNTY- A KEEPING
REGISTRIES ON STATUS- RACE-
CREED BORGEN BAND- IN I JUST
WONDER WHAT THE BILL WOULD DO
IN TERMS OF SUPERSEDING ARE
TEMPTING HIM MANDATE THAT YOU
TO REGISTRIES OF AGAIN COULD
NOT UNDERSTAND THE PUBLIC
RECORDS ISSUES- IN IN A COUNTY
THAT IF THE LITERALLY.
IDENTIFIED AND TRACKED IT WOULD
IT WOULD SEEM TO MEAN THAT THE
INQUIRE AS TO STATUS AND THEN
KEEP A REGISTRY AVAILABLE OR
SOME KIND OF TRACKING DEVICE
WHICH WOULD BE ORDINARILY A
PUBLIC RECORD- IN THE COURSE.
IN MY COUNTY- THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF CONFLICT WITH WITH ICE
AND FEDERAL AGENCIES IN TERMS
OF KEEPING THAT CAN INFORMATION-
YOU KNOW OUT OF THE HANDS OF
THOSE SAID- INTERESTED IN IN
DETAINEES- IMMIGRANT FAMILIES
ADDRESS OUR COMMITTED SO THAT'S
A LONG QUESTION I'M JUST REALLY
INTERESTED IN. WHERE THE BILL'S
GOING IN TERMS OF MANDATING
THAT IDENTIFICATION VERSUS. A
NON MANDATED OR IDENTIFYING
VERSES I THINK THE LANGUAGE- IN
MY PACKET HERE SAYS THE ITEM
YEAH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR AND THIS IS
BEEN. EVER SINCE I AUTHORED AB
NINE HUNDRED SOMETHING THAT I
STRUGGLED WITH BECAUSE I
RECALL. LEARNING FROM ONE OF
THE LEGAL AID CENTERS THAT THE
VERY FIRST ASSIDUOUS YOUTH WAS
PROTECTED UNDER AB NINE HUNDRED
AND TODD I WAS GOING TO BE IN
LOS ANGELES AND I MADE A POINT
TO GO AND VISIT NO E. THE YOUNG
MAN- BECAUSE I WANTED TO MEET
SOMEONEWHO IS IMPACTED BY THIS
BILL AND GET TO KNOW HIM IN AND
LEARN HIS STORY AND- I FELT
LIKE I GAINED SO MUCH
PERSPECTIVE. ABOUT WHY HE CAME
TO CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WHAT HE
WAS RUNNING FROM AND- HOW YOU
KNOW HOW HIS FAMILY HAD TREATED
HIM BEFORE HE HE MADE THAT
JOURNEY. AND- AND WE YOU KNOW
AT. I WOULD GO INTO A HOW MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HELPED
BY THIS BILL AND- AND WE DIDN'T
KNOW WE HAD NO IDEA WE DIDN'T
TRACK IT THOSE WHO GO AND APPLY
FOR SUGGESTS THERE IS NO WAY TO
COLLECT THAT DATA I'M EVEN THIS
BILL DOESN'T REALLY DO THAT.
BUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IF I
COUNTY KNOWS- AND LEARNS THAT
SOMEONE IS- UNDOCUMENTED THAT
DATE AND MAKE THE CONNECTION TO
LEGAL REPRESENTATION- THE
TRACKING IS FOR. WHAT I HOPE IS
GOING TO BUDGETARY PURPOSES IN
THE FUTURE SO WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY PEOPLE NEED THE SUPPORT-
AND WE CAN'T BUDGET FOR IT
AFFECTIVELY AND SO THE WAY THAT
WE'VE AND THIS BILL REALLY
STARTED OUT AS A FUNDING
MECHANISM BILL AND IT CAME CAME
DOWN TO A DATA BILL SO WHILE
THE COUNTIES MAKERS PERSONAL
CONNECTIONS FOR LEGAL SERVICES
FOR THE UNDOCUMENTED
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH. THE DATA
THAT IS COLLECTED AND IS DE
IDENTIFIED IS TO UNDERSTAND HOW
MANY YOUTH- MAY NEED TO BE THAT
MAY NEED TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
THE SERVICES- AND HOW MANY OF
THEM ARE ACTUALLY GETTING THE
SERVICES SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND
COSTS AND PERHAPS FUTURE-
LEGAL- BUDGETARY MEASURES. THE
APPRECIATE THAT I'M- I AM-
BECAUSE SOME WORRIED AND I'M
NOT TRYING THIS PUT HAIRS HERE
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT- WHEN IT
COMES TO THE DAY TO DAY.
REDUCTION OF THE DATA THAT TO
DE IDENTIFY. ALMOST IMPLIES
THAT YOU INITIALLY IDENTIFIED
RIGHT AND- IT IS VERY HARD TO
UNRING THAT BELL AS YOU AS WE
ALL KNOW HERE UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
OF WOOD COUNTY ASSEMBLES A
LIST. AND THEN FORWARD IT TO
THE STATE WITHOUT NAMES AND-
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION THE
ORIGINAL IDENTIFICATION IS
STILL THERE SOMEWHERE IS
SUBJECT TO- YOU KNOW A RECORDS
REQUEST WHICH- AGAIN HAS BEEN.
RELEASED I CAN ONLY SPEAK. TO
MY HOME COUNTY HAS BEEN
EXTREMELY PROBLEMATIC IN TERMS
OF- PROTECTING THOSE
INDIVIDUALS FROM. ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES SO- I APPRECIATE
THE WITH THE RESPONSE FROM ALL.
THE SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND
KEEP. A STUDYING HERE TO SEE
IF- I'M SATISFIED YOU KNOW
FURTHER AS IT AS IT MOVES
ALONG- BUT IT ALMOST FEELS LIKE
IT ALMOST FEELS LIKE THE BILL
WOULD NEED TO. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE WOULD NEED TO-
EXEMPT THE DATA THAT'S BEING
GATHERED FROM THE C. P. R. A.
YOU KNOW TO MAKE SURE THAT-
CARRIES DID NOT HAVE TO GIVE
THAT INFORMATION UP- YOU KNOW
TO THOSE WHO WERE OR TRYING FOR
OTHER PURPOSES TO. TO TRACK.
IDENTIFY IN SOME CASES PURSUE
YOU KNOW THE UNDOCUMENTED SO
THAT THAT'S WHAT THAT'S MY
CONCERN AND I WILL I CAN FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU AS FAR AS YOUR
MINOR NINE AGAIN- I WANT TO
REITERATE HER SUPPORT OF. THE
WORK IN THE ATTACK BUT I'M
SENSITIVE TO IT THAT THE OTHER
BILL I HAVE UP RIGHT NOW IS A
DATA BREACH NOTIFICATION
LEGISLATION INTRODUCED SO I'M
VERY SENSE OF THE POINT THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO MAKE IT AS FAR
AS KEEPING INFORMATION. IN YEAH
MY VOTE TODAY BECAUSE I. KNOW
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE WORKING. ON
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SAN CRITTERS THE ANSWER PAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU CENTER LIVING FOR BRING
THIS BILL FORD- CERTAINLY WE
WANT ARE UNDOCUMENTED- FIRST
USED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE INFORMATION THEY NEED-
THAT MIGHT ALLOW THEM TO
ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO BE AN-
STANDS COUNTRY- IT'S
APPROPRIATE SO I GUESS THAT
COUPLE QUESTIONS WELL THE SORT
TOGETHER SO IT SAYS BEST
EFFORTS SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS WHAT DEFINES BEST EFFORT.
AND THEN SECONDARILY RELATED TO
THAT IS YOU KNOW WE FUNDED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY THROUGH THE FARM
SOCIAL SERVICES A PROGRAM ON
CALIFORNIA PROVIDE ACTUALLY
STATE FUNDED IMMIGRATION-
ADVISER OR LEGAL COUNSEL SO- IS
THE ERROR I THOUGHT ABOUT-
INSTRUCTING ACTUALLY AGAIN
THESE FOSTER USER EASY TO AND
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICE PROGRAMS
RIGHT- THAT- THAT THAT THAT
MINIMUM- IF THERE ISN'T A LOCAL
IMMIGRATION SERVICE THEY CAN
MAKE A FOR ALL TO THAT THERE'S
OF THESE REFERRAL PERHAPS OF
THE STATE ONE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM- SO AS FAR THEIR BEST
EFFORTS SO I GUESS- THAT THAT'S
MY QUESTION WHAT'S BEST EFFORT
AND- IS THIS PERHAPS. MAYBE
ARTICULATING DATA WHETHER THE
LEGISLATION SOME DIRECTION SO
THAT SO THAT SO THAT WE CAN BE
MORE SURE TO THAT- FOSTER YOU
STUDIES ON SECOND THOUGHT SHE'D
ACTUALLY GET ACCESS TO.
IMMIGRATION COUNSEL YEAH I MEAN
THIS IS FAR FROM A MANDATE THAT
THEY HAVE TO DO ANYTHING BUT I
THINK THAT THE BEST EFFORTS IS
REFLECTIVE OF ONE THAT THEY MAY
OR MAY NOT KNOW THE STATUS AND
THEN TO OF COURSE WHETHER OR
NOT THERE IS A LEGAL AID-
ORGANIZATION OR FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES AND THE POINT TO THE
BILL IS LET'S UNDERSTAND WHAT
THIS POPULATION IS LIKE THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY MAKE IT POSSIBLE-
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE FLEEING
ABUSE ABANDONMENT NEGLECT. TO
BE SAFE SEEK ASYLUM IN
CALIFORNIA AS SO MANY HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO- WHEN THOSE RESOURCES
HAVE BEEN THERE AND WHEN
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE. TO IDENTIFY-
THE STATUS- THANK YOU I
CERTAINLY. THE THIS FIRST OF
ALL. THE FOURTEENTH MAY THE
NECESSARY TO REVEAL SO THAT
THAT'S- BUT ALSO I THINK ON THE
SOCIAL SERVICE SIDE- THAT
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE'RE ALSO
FUNDING. NOT TO SAY THAT WE CAN
PERHAPS GIVE MORE MONEY BUT-
IMMIGRATION COUNSEL. EVEN IF
THERE WASN'T LOCAL AVAILABLE
ABILITY TO- AT LEAST THERE
MIGHT BE ANOTHER CHANNEL THAT
THEY COULD. DIE ACCESS- THROUGH
BEST EFFORTS. I ALSO JUST STEP
BEFORE I CONCLUDE IS- I DID
MAKE NOTE THAT THE WITNESS WHO
TESTIFIED MENTION MY COUNTY
SACRAMENTO COUNTY IS NOT BE
PARTICULARLY HELPFUL SO I LOOK
FOR THE FOLLOWING UP. WITH THAT
WITNESS ON THAT WE SHOULD DO
BETTER HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. AND WITH THAT- I
CERTAINLY I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE
YOUR BILL. TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A SENATOR PAN AND AT
THIS MOMENT A WITH THE MOTION
I'LL- HOW CAN AFFECT YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE FOR. A
CLOSING STATEMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'M SURE THANK YOU
FOR THE DELIBERATION AGAIN ON
THIS IMPORTANT AND COMPLEX
ISSUE AFFECTING MANY- HOPEFUL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU ARE SO
FAST FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU ALSO
HAVE A MOTION MADE BY A SENATOR
PAN ON- CONSULTING Q. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THIS MEASURE.
AB EIGHT TO NINE BY LEVINE THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY HER TADO I FURTADO
I'D JONES. CORTESE HI COURTESY
I COM LONGER HI CONLOGUE ARE
AYE PAN HI AND I. THANK YOU
OFFICES BELONG CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. AND ATTACKS OF
AGENDA ITEM FOURTEEN. AB ONE
TWO TWO ZERO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS THREE OF US. AND PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT AB TWELVE TWENTY AM I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
SUMMARIZED ON PAGE NINE OF THE
ANALYSIS. LAST SESSION I
AUTHORED AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE
WHICH WAS AN ATTEMPT TO DEVELOP
A COMPREHENSIVE POLICY SOLUTION
FOR THE ISSUE OF HOMELESSNESS.
AB TWELVE TWENTY IN THE FORM
BEFORE YOU TODAY IS THE RESULT
OF ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
RESTRUCTURING CHANGES. SO WE
CAN ENSURE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING
GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY AND
OVERSIGHT TO HOW THE STATE IS
COMBATING HOMELESSNESS. AB
TWELVE TWENTY MAKES A NUMBER OF
STRUCTURAL CHANGES TO THE
CURRENT HOMELESS COORDINATING
AND FINANCING COUNCIL. THIS
MEASURE RENAME RENAMES THE
HOMELESS COUNCIL TO THE
CALIFORNIA INTERAGENCY COUNCIL
ON HOMELESSNESS. THIS NAME
CHANGE MORE ACCURATELY
REPRESENTS THE PURPOSE OF THE
COUNCIL I WILL SET THE STAGE
FOR THE RESTRUCTURING OF THE
COUNCIL MEMBERSHIP IN
COMMITTEES. MEMBERSHIP WILL
CONSIST OF DIRECTORS AND
SECRETARIES OF THE STATE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO HAVE LIVED
OF EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS
INCLUDING UNACCOMPANIED YOUTH
UNDER TWENTY FIVE YEARS OF AGE.
IN MARCH THE HOMELESS COUNCIL
ADOPTED ITS FIRST EVER ACTION
PLAN FOR PREVENTING AND ENDING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA THE
ACTION PLAN PROVIDES THE
DETAILS ON HOW THE HOMELESS
COUNCIL WILL ACHIEVE ITS GOALS.
THIS PLAN COMES AT A CRITICAL
TIME AS THE BIDEN HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION IS BEGINNING TO
FOCUS ON THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS AS SUCH THE STATE
MUST ENSURE PROPER AND
EFFICIENT COORDINATION AMONG
STATE AGENCIES DEPARTMENTS AND
OTHER RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS.
OTHER STATES IN THE COUNTRY
HAVE SIMILAR COUNCIL STRUCTURES
SO THIS IS A STANDARD MODEL.
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS DEDICATED
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS WHILE STATE
FUNDING PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE
IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING ALONE WILL
NOT SOLVE SYSTEMIC ISSUES. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT THE COUNCIL IS
COMPROMISE OF STATE LEADERS AND
DEPARTMENT HEADS WHO ARE BEST
EQUIPPED TO EFFECTIVELY
COORDINATE AND RESPOND TO
HOMELESSNESS. TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I HAVE
SHARON REPORT DIRECTOR OF THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
CENTER RIVAS A LOTTERY PLEASE
BRING ON TO THE LINER- THE MAIN
WITNESS- SHARON REPORT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY I BELIEVE YOU THREE
MINUTES MAXIMUM. THANK YOU
SHARON MEMBERS I'M SHARON
REPORT WITH THE CORPORATION FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING A SUPPORTER
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER DEFENSE AT
TWELVE TWENTY. BATES THROUGHOUT
THE NATION HAVE CREATED
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS TO COORDINATE THE
ACTIVITIES OF DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES IMPACTING ON MARTHA.
IN FEBRUARY OUR STATE AUDITOR
STATED AT LEAST NINE STATE
AGENCIES ADMINISTER AND OVERSEE
FORTY ONE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
THAT PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
PURPOSES RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS. IT DRASTIC
DISJOINTED FRAGMENTED NATURE OF
THE STATE'S RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED AND GOVERNOR BROWN
SIGNED SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TO
CREATE THE HOMER COORDINATING
AND FINANCING COUNCIL. AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS SAID THE
COORDINATING COUNCIL RECENTLY
ADOPTED AN ACTION PLAN TO
FOSTER STRONGER COOPERATION
BETWEEN THE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. AB TWELVE TWENTY
WOULD STRENGTHEN THE COUNCIL'S
MECCA IT REFORM THE COUNCIL TO
FOLLOW THE MODELS AT THE U. S.
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS AND OTHER MODEL
STATE HEAD OF- OPERATED ACTIVE
H. INTERAGENCY COUNCIL. THE
FIRM MUNGER CHANGES WOULD BE TO
ENSURE REPRESENTATIVES OF
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES WERE
PROFICIENT MAKING AUTHORITY ARE
SITTING ON THE COUNCIL NOT JUST
TO UPDATE COUNCIL MEMBER
AGENCIES ON STATE WORK BETTER
HOLD HONEST CONVERSATIONS ON
PATHWAYS THE SOLUTION. WE ARE
HOPEFUL THESE CHANGES COULD
LEAD TO COLLABORATION THAT WILL
REDUCE DISCHARGES FROM STATE
FUNDED INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS
AND THE HOMEOWNER. AND STRONG
RECORDED COORDINATION OF STATE
RESOURCES. I APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BECAUSE
DEDICATION TO SOLVING
HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA AND
I ASK FOR YOUR EYES. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH- THEY'LL
MOVE ONTO DIGITAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND JUST TO CLARIFY
SORRY MIGHT MISS THIS PART WITH
THEIR AMENDMENTS- THAT TO BE
TAKEN HERE AND YOU SAID THAT
THIS MEANT I ACCEPTED OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A MEMBER
RIGHT NOW THE MOVE ONTO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWELVE TWENTY I WILL
BEGIN IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE SEEN ON ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE LET'S MOVE TO RUN TWENTY
FORTY. AND DESERVE NO IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE TWENTY NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE N. ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NONE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU- AND
ACTUALLY- THAT JUST WANT TO
QUICKLY STEP THERE IS NO ONE
REGISTERED FOR LEAD OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY ON THIS BILLS ARE AN
OPTION FOR ME OKAY SO THERE'S
NO ONE AND- FOR LEAD OPPOSITION
SO WILL THEN TAKE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY TWELVE TWENTY OF THE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE SEEN ON.
PLEASE BRING ON THE LINE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY TWELVE TWENTY. AND IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWELVE TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO ONE IN OUR QUEUE
ALL RIGHT PLEASE CONTINUE THANK
YOU MONTROSE BRING BACK FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WITH OKAY
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
CORTESE- SAYING NO OTHER TAKES
MUCH BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- CERTAINLY WE'VE SEEN
DODD AND MANY OTHER THE NEED TO
COORDINATE THEIR COURT HOMELESS
EFFORTS WOULD LIKE. YEAH FIRST
IT'S TIME THAT WE RISK AND
EMPOWER THE CALIFORNIA
INTERAGENCY COUNCIL ON
HOMELESSNESS TO SERVE AS A
STATE WHITE OF FACILITATOR
COORDINATOR M. POLICY DEVELOPER
TO END HOMELESSNESS IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
THREE OF THEM- SO. MOTIONS
MOVED BY A CERTAIN. IS TO PASS
AND FOR AMEND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE HOUSE. I CONSULT CAME
CALL THE OLL. AB ONE TWO TWO
ZERO. HER TADO. JONES CORTESE I
RTZ I KAMARG I COMPLY I'D HI AN
ONLINE. THE BILL'S CAR THREE
ZERO THE BILL ON THANKS VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY- FINALLY WE
HAVE A FOURTEENTH ONE SUMMER
REYES SAID WE ARE STILL. WILL
WAITING FOR SOME A RACE. AND I
PRESUME SHE'S BEEN. AT TEN OKAY.
I AND I BLEW EVERYONE ARE. SO-
WE'RE WAITING FOR SOME A RACE
BUT- CENTER JONES- YOU ARE THE
VICE CHAIR BUT YOU WISH I CAN
CONTINUE TO SLIP CALLS FOR YOU
TO CAST VOTES EVERY GREAT I
HAVE TO. OKAY THAT'S GOING TO
GO DO THAT YOU'RE GONNA A GREAT
JOB. YEAH OKAY ALL RIGHT SO- IN
IOWA A CONSOLE SETTLE IN AS WE
DO CALL. ALL RIGHT. OKAY SO
JUST GO DOWN A ORDER- SO- K. SO
WE JUST HAVE IN HER LAST BILL
SO OKAY SO LET'S THE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY TWO TO ONE BY SOME
MEMBER SAW. AND THE MOST IS
PASS AMENDED BUT REFER TO REFER
TO CAMINO PRO SECOND PLEASE THE
ROLL OF APPS MEMBERS AB TWO TWO
ONE JONES. JOHN NOW. THREE ONE
OKAY OF SO THE BILL IS OUT. FOR
ONE. LET'S MOVE ON TO A NUMBER
TWO A SIX BIAS MEMBER- THE
MOTIONS TO PASS FLEA FIRST FOR
YOUR FIRST CA DO- CONSULT CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT AND- AB SIX
SEVENTY JOHN. JONES I. BY A
THAT BILL IS OUT. FIVE ZERO.
ALL RIGHT- NEXT BILL IS IN THE
THREE THIRTY SIXTY BY SOME TWO.
OF NO NONSENSE THANK NOT THAT
YOUNG SORRY THANKS BILLS I'M
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY THIRTY
SIXTY EIGHT BY SUMMER CALDERON
STEVE GROUP REAR TO COMMIT
PROPERTY- CAN PLEASE THE ROLL
THAT MEMBERS. AB THIRTY SIXTY
EIGHT JOHN. JONES NOW. FOR ONE
WORK OKAY THAT BILLS OUT FOR
TWO. NEXT ITEM ITEM NUMBER SIX
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY BY SUMMER-
PHILIP TO DO TO DO A- IN THE
MOST IS- DO PASSED FIRST ROOF
COMMITTEE- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE OF APPS MEMBERS AB.
FOUR SIX ONE JONES. JONES BY.
THANK YOU OKAY. THAT WILL IS
OUT FOR ZERO NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHT FOUR NINE
NINE SUMMER BLANCA RUBIO AND
THE THERE IS- YOU PASS A MAN
BUT FIRST TO. AMEND REFERRED
COMMITTEE ON- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE NUMBER AB FOUR NINE
NINE. JONES I. THE BILL IS.
FIVE ZERO. NEXT TIMES I'M
NUMBER EIGHT FIVE NINETY TWO BY
SO FREE- BILL IS A TO PASS BUT
FOR. FIRST AMENDED REAR AS A
BUT FIRST AND REFER COMMITTEE
ON. I CONSULT PLEASE CALL ROLL
THAT MEMBERS IT. FIVE NINETY
TWO. JOHN FIVE. YEAH THAT BILL
ABOUT FIVE ZERO NEXT ITEM IS I
NUMBER HELLO AB EIGHT EIGHT BY
SOME STATES AND THE MOTION IS
THE PATH AND THEN THE FIRST THE
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON.
CONSULTING CALL THE ROLL AFTER
MEMBERS AB EIGHT OH JONES.
JONES NOT VOTING. THREE ZERO.
THAT BILLS OUT FOR ZERO NEXT
ITEM ITEM TWO EIGHT EIGHT TWO
NINE BUT MEMBERS. MOTIONS TO
PASS THE FIRST REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL MEMBERS AB EIGHT TO NINE
JOE. JONES I- THAT BILL OUT
FIVES- C. WE JUST DID FOURTEEN
RICARDO WASN'T HERE OKAY YEAH
SO OUT NUMBER FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWELVE TWENTY FIVE SUMMER LOOSE
REAR RIVAS- THAT MOTIONS DO AS
AMENDED FIRST REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. I
CANCELED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS. EIGHT ONE TWO
TWO HER TADO. JONES YEAH. YES
YEAH THAT'S A SUMMER ARMS ARE
TELLING FONG I'M SORRY YEAH. AS
WASN'T SHE WASN'T HERE SO.
CLIMBING AB ONE TWO TWO ZERO
GEL. JONES NOW OKAY SO WILL
HOLD THAT THE LAW CALL. THREE
ONE. OKAY AND FINE WE HAVE THE
CONSENT. SO HAVE A FOUR ITEMS
ON THE CAN- AS ED. I SOON YOU
KNOW WHAT ARE- SO CONSULT-
PLEASE GO THE ROLL THEM MEMBERS
BECAUSE THEY CAN. YOURSELF AND
SAY OKAY. DON'T CALL THE ROLL
ON THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
CONSENT. FOR THE CALENDAR JONES.
J. I'D OKAY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OUT FIVE ZERO. OKAY
THAT- BASICALLY IS TO SAY
LIFTING OF THE CALLS WITH HAVE
ONE BY BILL LESS HERE BUT I
THINK YOU'RE COVERED FOR ALL
THE. THE OTHERS ARE YEAH WE ARE.
CAN WILL THEN MOVE TO MOVE BACK
TO EITHER NUMBER FOUR A TWELVE.
OF ICE MEMBER LIEU READ. AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AMENDED
BY FIRST WE TO COME ON HOUSING
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OUT
MEMBERS. AB ONE TWO ZERO HER
TALK I FOR TITLE I. THAT BILLS
OUT FOR ONE. OKAY I'M MONEY
HANDED TO GET BACK.
TO AT THIS
MOMENTO WE ARE WAITING FOR OUR
LAST SPEAKER TO- PRESENT AND WE
WILL TAKE A BRIEF- RECESS. FOR
AT TEN MINUTES SOME OVER BACK
AT. FOR FIFTEEN. FORTY FOR
THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE HERE WITH US-
PROJECT TO ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
AB. ONE FOUR SIX ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RADIUS- PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHEN THEY RETURN. I
PRESENT TO YOU AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE FOR SIX TO ENSURE
IMMIGRANTS TO QUALIFY FOR STATE
AND LOCAL BENEFITS DO NOT GO
WITHOUT THE CRITICAL SERVICES
AND RESOURCES THEY NEED. TO
REMAIN HEALTHY. AND THIS IS A
DURING THE TIME OF THEIR WAY TO
FOR YOU GUYS STATES. IN A
BIGGER SERVICES. FOR APPROVAL
OF THEIR APPLICATION. CURRENTLY
APPLICANTS OF U. VISAS T. VISAS
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
STATUS SEEKERS AND VIOLENCE
AGAINST WOMEN ACT PETITIONERS.
CAN ACCESS STATE AND LOCAL
BENEFITS IN CALIFORNIA HOWEVER
IN ORDER TO ACCESS THESE
BENEFITS AND THE SERVICES. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MUST GIVE
NOTICE THAT THEY HAVE APPROVED
THEIR APPLICATION AND IT IS
THEN THAT APPLICANTS CAN
RECEIVE SERVICES. AS APPLICANTS
WAIT FOR THIS APPROVAL AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THEY MAY GO
WITHOUT THESE CRITICAL SERVICES
THE TIME IN WHICH AN APPLICANT
MIGHT MIGHT GO WITHOUT SERVICES
HAS ONLY INCREASED AS THE PET
PANDEMIC HAS CREATED. DELAYS IN
THE U. S. IMMIGRATION SERVICE
IS PROCESSING TIME. AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE WOULD ALLOW U. VISA
TV'S ASYLUM SEEKERS AND
QUALIFIED WOMEN AND YOUTH. TO
ACCESS STATE AND LOCAL
RESOURCES ONCE THEY FILE THEIR
APPLICATION WITH IMMIGRATION
SERVICES EFFECTIVELY CLOSING
THE GAP IN WHICH AN APPLICANT
MIGHT GO WITHOUT SERVICES. AND
ENSURING THE NEEDS OF
APPLICANTS. ARE MET THIS BILL
ENJOYS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS NO OPPOSITION. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
IS CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND LISA KNEW STROM
WITH BAY AREA LEGAL AID. DO WE
DO WE HAVE- MISTERS ESSENTIALS
ON THE CALL. YEAH- OUR GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
RESPONSES POLICY ADVOCATE WITH
AND I'M ALL. WE'RE PROUD TO BE
ONE OF THE SPOTS OF AB FOURTEEN
ONE. AND TWO THOUSAND SIX FIVE
TWO THOUSAND THREE COUNTS
BECAME THE AND- AS FIFTY
SIXTEEN BY THEN THE NURSE THAT
YOU'RE TO PROVIDE STATE AND
LOCAL SOCIAL SIR THE THOUSAND
ONE RENT. AN ACT POLICY IN
ORDER. AND WILL SEARCH FOR. ARE
GAP IN SERVICE LIKE BE VERY
CRITICAL ALL IN ORDER OR- GREAT
NUMBER VIA YOU HAVE OFTEN WE'VE
RECEIVED NUMEROUS. OF CURRENTLY
FIGURE I'M NOT BEING ABLE TO
THE PROPER SO THE ARE IN.
REPORT AB FORTY SIXTY ONE
ACADEMICS WHO ARE SEEKING
MONETARY FORMS OF RELIEF AND
CLOSE THE GAP OF SERVICES TO
ENSURE THAT THEIR HOUSE AND
SAFETY COMES FIRST DURING THESE
NORMAL TIMES OF THEIR
EXPERIENCE A GREAT APPROACH IN
THEIR LIFE. IS FOR THESE.
REASONS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU I DO WE
HAVE A LEGAL NUMBER TWO. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAME IF WE FINISH
TRIM. HERNING WITH AREA LEGAL
AID. A FEW YEARS AGO MY OFFICE
HELP THE SURVIVOR OF ABUSE WHO
WAS UNDOCUMENTED AND LIKE MANY
SURVIVORS SHE NEEDED CAL WORKS
BUT WITH ELIGIBLE ONLY FOR HER
STUDENTS AND CHILDREN ONCE WE
FILED FOR YOU BEING THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO HELP HER GET STATE
FUNDED CAL WORKS FOR HERSELF
ABOUT A HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH. AND WHEN SHE THANKED US
SHE EXPLAINED SHE WAS SO
GRATEFUL BECAUSE SHE'D BEEN
ABOUT TO DROP A RESTRAINING
ORDER AGAINST HER ABUSER
BECAUSE HE HAD PROMISED AN
EXTRA HUNDRED DOLLARS IN CHILD
SUPPORT EACH MONTH AND SHE
DESPERATELY NEEDED THAT MONEY
TO MAKE ENDS MEET. WITH THAT
LITTLE EXTRA BIT OF TOWERS SHE
COULD AFFORD TO KEEP THE
PROTECTIVE ORDER IN PLACE. I
THOUGHT OF THE THREE. WHEN THEY
LEGAL WORK WITH ANOTHER
UNDOCUMENTED SURVIVORS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A DIFFERENT
IMMIGRATION PATHWAY UNDER THE
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN ACT. AND
ONCE SHE FILED HER VOLATILE
PETITION IT WOULD BE ABOUT FOUR
MONTHS UNTIL SHE WAS ELIGIBLE
FOR FEDERALLY FUNDED BENEFIT.
PERFORMANCE MIGHT NOT SEEM LIKE
TAT LONG THE PROSPECT OF FOR
MONTHS WITH NO INCOME OR
FINANCIAL SUPPORT WHAT'S WEBER
WAS SO TERRIFYING. THAT THE
CLIENT ULTIMATELY DECIDED TO
STAY WITH HER ABUSER. AB FORTY
SIXTY ONE WOULD OFFER ACCESS TO
STATE PUBLIC BENEFITS ON EQUAL
FOOTING FOR IMMIGRANT SURVIVORS
FOLLOWING DIFFERENT SURVIVOR
BASED PASSED A LAWFUL STATUS.
IT WOULD COVER INDIVIDUALS WHO
APPLIED FOR RELIEF UNDER OUR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH WITH APPLIED
FOR SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
STATUS. IN PERSON TO PROPERLY
FILED AN APPLICATION FOR
ASYLUM. CHILDREN ELIGIBLE FOR
SUGGEST WE GET SERVICES DURING
A SHORT A CRITICAL PERIOD
BEFORE THEY CAN GET FEDERAL
BENEFITS. WITH AN ADVOCATE
RECENTLY WHO HAD A THREE YEAR
OLD HE JUST CLIENT WHO IS TO BE
USED BEEN ABANDONED BY PARENTS
AND BEING CARED FOR BY GRANDMA
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. RIGHT NOW
GRAHAM HAS NO ACCESS TO ANY
SERVICES OR BENEFIT. GRANDMA
CAN'T AFFORD TO CARE FOR HIM. I
LIVE AT RISK OF ENTERING
FOSTER. THIS BILL WOULD HELP
THE FAMILY QUALIFY FOR CAL
WORKS INCREASE FINANCIAL
STABILITY AND DECREASE RISK THE
CHILD OF THE TRAUMA OF GOING
INTO FOSTER CARE AND THE NEED
FOR MORE INTENSIVE SERVICES.
FOR MOST OF THE INDIVIDUALS
IMPACTED THE AMOUNT OF TIME AND
BENEFITS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
RELATIVELY SMALL BUT FOR THESE
INDIVIDUALS ACCESS TO SOCIAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORT CAN BE
LIFE ALTERING. FOR THIS REASON
THEY LEGAL SUPPORT. SB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TEST. WILL I HAD TO-
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL- HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. NAY NONE OF ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NO NO ONE THERE
AND- MOVING ON TOWARD TOTAL
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN SUPPORT
OF AB. FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE. IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT. NOW WE DO HAVE TO IN
OUR QUEUE AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
GO TO LINE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I HAVE PERFECTED
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. FIND ONE
TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE- PLEASE CONTINUE.
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL- BUT WE
WILL MOVE TO A PUBLIC COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION- HERE FORTY TWO
OH THREE. SEEING NONE OF OUR
TWENTY FORTY. AND NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO- THAT THERE'S NONE
THERE AT MOVING ON TO TALKING
PUBLIC COMMENT LINE IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE AND
IF WE HAVE ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING- TO TESTIFY PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY THANK
YOU. IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. TEN ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE IN OUR QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE THANK YOU ARE AND WILL
HAVE UP TO QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND WE HAVE ONE FROM SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU FOR READING THIS
BILL FOR TO MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO A CLOSE ON THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVALS. THANK YOU SO WE
HAVE. A MOTION ON THIS BILL-
AND CONSULTANT CAN YOU BUY
CENTER PAN CONSULTING YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE BY RAISE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS HER TADO HI. FOR
TITLE II JONES. CORTESE COM
LONGER PAN HI AND I. AND WE
WILL PLACE A BILL ON CALL BACK
YOU MENTIONED YOU.
AT THIS
POINT WILL DISTURB A WAIT FOR
MEMBERS TO COME BACK ON A LIFT
AT THE CALL ON. THE BILL'S.
THANK.
OUR CONSULTING CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON- THE
BILL BUT IS ON CALL. AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY ONE BY RAAS THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS BUT FIRST BE
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS JONES. JONES BY.
THE BILL WILL REMAIN ON CALL.
OKAY M. CONSULTANT CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THAT ON
THE BILL THAT IS ON CALL. AB
ONE FOUR SIX ONE BY RAY IS THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CORTESE. BY
CORTESE I COME LONGER. THE BILL
IS FOUR ZERO ONE THAT BILL IS
OUT- I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION-
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA FOR TODAY THE SENATE
IS THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE IS KNOWLEDGE ADJOURNED